Huh.
I think it's very weird to me. Uh, personally personally weird
when when H3 actually comes out, when Ethan comes out and says,
"Yes, I was planning to sue these people. It's been my plan to
sue these people all along." I personally, and listen, legally,
that doesn't mean he's not able to do it, right? Legally, he
still has every leg to stand on. I'm just saying for me personally,
it's very, very bizarre that he went and registered this with
the express purpose of trying to get statutory damages against
people reacting. and and he's going to say now that these people
helped him and he's only going after these three people. I don't
believe that to be true, but we'll we'll see.
Hello. Hello. Hello. I'm actually just going to jump right over
this cuz this video is working. Okay. Hello. Hello. Hello. How's
it going, guys? How we doing today? How we doing? How we feeling?
How's it going? Hello. What's up? What's up? What's up? What's
up, Cherry? What's up, guys?
It's a crazy day today. It is content nuke day. Oh my goodness.
Uh I think I should switch Cherry back over to the other avatar
now that I'm looking at it. Okay, let me let me take a look here.
Take a look. What's up, Cherry? How's it going? What's up? What's
up? Uh it's going good. That's good. I think we're going to have
a very interesting day today cuz it seems like a lot of people
are totally on Ethan Klein's side through uh him suing these
creators. Really? And I kind of wonder. Yeah, I kind of wonder
if they're like thinking of the implications of this at all.
But we'll see. I'm sure some people are fine with it. I just
don't understand why if Who are the people supporting him? Uh
I can see I can see some people doing it. Okay. I've heard a
lot of people are psyched about it. I've heard Okay, we'll we'll
have to go through on the stream and see because I've not actually
looked through all of it myself to be honest with you. We will
we'll see as we go along. Can I make you bigger? I can make you
bigger.
Boom. Boom. Boom. There we go. Too big. Better. Better. Better.
No, it was good before. Sorry. Getting used to the new avatars
and stuff. There we go. There we go. Oh my god. The music is
a little too loud for the rest of the stream, but let me fix
that really quickly. Back down. Okay, guys. What's up? Entrament
kind of. Uh, well, enttrapment and not entrapment. Okay, it's
it's
Trust me, Ethan has been planning this for a long time. And there's
a there's breadcrumbs showing he's been planning it for a long
time. And I think we're going to go through some of that today.
I It was obvious he was going to sue people. He wanted to sue
people the entire time. He was planning to sue people. And I
think when he was baiting people to watch his content, nuke,
it was with thoughts that he would be suing people. Okay. How
weird. How weird is that that like
before all this happened, Ethan just knew he was going to go
on some sort of like legal arc? Yeah, it it is weird. It is weird.
How could he have possibly known that he could do certain things?
How could he know? Oh my goodness. There's It's going to be speaking
in code for a little bit off the bat, guys. Okay. Could be some
code code words, code phrases going on. We'll see how it goes.
Uh Discord is locked until I think 10 retweets and 30 likes on
the blastoff tweet, guys. So, Discord gen chat will be locked,
but that's okay cuz you guys want to be here in the kick chat
anyway or the the Twitch chat. Either one. I know you guys want
to be here. All right. So, good luck. Good luck everybody. We
didn't like that Discord anyway. Does not matter what his motivation
is. It absolutely does matter, Tiska. And I understand that you
don't care. Lots of people, from what I can tell, lots of people
um they just don't they don't really care. They're just like,
"Oh, Casey Tron's getting with Denim's getting with Frogen getting
with." That's awesome. I hate those people.
That's so cool. I hate those guys. Lots of people they get [__]
with. They just don't they don't really I should post this video
on my timeline or on my reply.
If Tommy C can be making like 15 hours of content just talking
about how he doesn't trust Chad Logic. I feel like I can complain
about Ethan here. Like there's plenty here to be like, "Yeah,
I don't trust you, Ethan." Is this the most pathetic thing Ethan's
done? Well, the sad thing is is Ethan probably has a point about
React content, right? I've seen I I don't know like uh I want
to say 45 seconds or so of the content nuke, right? And I know
he brings up XQC and his arguments with XQC cuz we remember these
arguments with XQC and they're like kind of valid arguments,
but then why isn't he going after anybody who actually affects
other creators? Like these people have such a tiny impact. I
don't understand why then why why does he feel the need to go
after them? It's not even that they just have a tiny impact.
It's like he looked for a foolproof way to be able to get them
without, I don't know, proving his
Yeah, exactly. I think like the way that I described it before
is like the way that he went about it, he wanted to be able to
hit someone for reacting to his content with like the bumpers
up if you like you're bowling or whatever. Like he's keeping
the bumpers up in in order to go after these people and he's
like, "Oh, I'm such a good bowler. I'm such a good bowler." and
then put the bumpers down. If you're such a good bowler, how
about you sue somebody who I don't know wears your house on his
wrist? Yeah, this is this is he just wants to go after these
people. And um he's he's created a circumstance and they helped
create the circumstance. But if you guys don't know, okay, how
this how this works,
that's how court works. Yeah, TA, but what are his damages?
What are his actual damages? Here's here's why it's it's different.
Okay. In in basically all cases where Ethan just had this happen
and he wasn't actually trying to set a trap for these people
to react so he could sue them, his actual damages from froen
watching his are like $4.25,
right? So he can sue, but the actual damages are nothing.
Damages are outlined. I know the damages are outlined. They're
nothing. They're nothing. It's such a insane thing to to try
to claim damages here. Why not DMCA first? That's a great question,
Bruise by Loe. And that's because if you guys don't remember,
uh, a certain certain person came onto this stream a couple months
ago and explained that if you register your content with the
Library of Congress. Okay, if you do that, within 3 months of
that content being published for the first time, you actually
gain access to a new set of damages. And this was, I believe,
set up so that places like uh so like record companies could
sue like Napster and Right. So if you go and create some content
and you register it with the Library of Congress, you actually
gain like statutory damages. So you can go after tiny people
who who shared your your MP3 on Napster four times. Within like
the first 3 months, you're saying, right? With as long as you
register it within the first 3 months. It doesn't have to be
within 3 months of the violation, right? As long as it's registered.
As long as it's registered, you can go after people with no damages.
Basically, you can actually hurt them. This allowed record companies
to bully people who shared their songs like eight times. Yeah.
I I'm going to get $1.5 million from you. That's who Ethan Klein
is now. Ethan Klein is the record companies in like the Napster
dispute. No. No. He's not just He's not just the record companies.
Cuz these record companies didn't go to people like, "Oh, listen
to my song. Listen to my song. Hassan, listen to my song. Hassan,
listen to my Hassan. Go on your stream and live react to it.
Hassan, do Hassan react. React. Hassan, you won't play my video."
knowing the whole time that he's doing some gay op. I'm going
to sue you. Exactly. What are the damages for streaming anime
and sporting events with React content?
Damages are low, right? Damages are low. The way the way it works,
the way copyright law works, okay, is you should be able to sue
for actual damages, right? If you are being harmed by somebody,
if somebody is tangibly harming you, you should be able to sue
them. And actually, you're entitled to sue them for whatever
the harm is. But the issue here is that Ethan is not going to
sue them for the harm because that would never be worth it, right?
He is going to sue them for statutory damages. So, because he
has his his thing registered at the Library of Congress, they
can actually sue per violation for up to $150,000
statutory damages, not not actual damages. So, there's no way
he didn't get he wasn't damaged for anywhere near $150,000,
right? He was damaged for far less than that. But it doesn't
matter what he's actually damaged for. He just wants to bully
these people. And he registered this stuff before he ever actually
before he ever actually um published the content nuke. And I
don't know if you guys remember when the content nuke was originally
published, but why why did he keep going, "Oh, I'm going to delay
it." Remember, everybody was like, "Oh, oh, this this uh Crazy
Destiny stuff came out. Ethan's delaying his content nuke a week."
Was he doing that or was he waiting a week because his copyright
stuff hadn't been registered? Also, I have a question.
Yeah, that is uh I do really want to know that as well. Uh the
Supreme Kai makes a good point. He's allowed to permit individuals
to use his content. That's part of owning something you make.
The question is if he is publicly
um permitting Hassan to use it, then why will he like why is
he going after people associated with Hassan?
Should that not hurt his his case? like, oh, you were willing
to let this huge creator rewatch and commentate on your video,
but here is somebody with like 120th of their audience and you're
suing this person. Yeah. And like listen, Jesus is
uh stuff going on. Yeah. The idea that you would give somebody
like who eclipse is their size explicit content and like begging
for that is very bizarre.
We actually we have this clip right here. I'm told this is uh
Ethan giving his stance on React content a little while back.
Let's uh let's check this out. Let's see what's going on here.
This doesn't count. He was fat here. Much happier person when
he was fat, I think. Skip the first 10 seconds.
Um Okay. Oh, I want to say uh a little show note. Um
okay. Uh Supreme, that does hurt them. Yes, that will hurt them
in the lawsuit that they're trying to say that here's unfortunately
for for their sake or fortunately unfortunately I'm not sure.
I do believe the actual fact of the matter matters as much or
more than what their like intent was. Right? If I take a picture
during the Super Bowl of like a touchdown catch and then I go
and say like that's based off of their their their stream or
whatever. I clip like two seconds off of it and I say I'm doing
this so that they won't get as much money. I post a clip to YouTube.
It's like if I'm not doing any damage, if nobody ever sees that
thing, I don't know. Yeah, I really don't know. I don't know
if that's going to count. What about this? What about this? What
if they go to court and they say, "Oh, sir, that's a performance."
I just on stream I play the part of like an evil feminist.
So, I just say those things as part of my character. Yeah. But
no, I was just reacting to it the way that like anybody would
react to content.
Yeah, exactly. Uh Ozel's correct that it still doesn't mean that
their content wasn't transformative or that they didn't make
their content transformative or even that they don't think their
content is transformative and they're just arguing this. Right.
So, I I think it's embarrassing to to use copyright law to abuse
it as a bully. If you want to make a point about, you know, lazy
reactions and stuff, there's a whole bunch of points that you
could make. There's a whole bunch of people you could actually
go after, right? All I want Ethan to do here is come out and
admit that you know what? I'm not trying to make a point about
copyright. I am personally trying to bully these people cuz I
don't like them. That's that's all he has to do. You want to
be a bully as our friend. What What is
the conflict? He is actually just being Israel, right? A little
bit maybe.
Sure. And then Hassan really isn't the Hassan is like the innocent
people, the Palestinians and all of these women around him. They
are. And so Ethan just wants to hit the terrorists. Bro, I think
I'm tripping. Okay. All right. I I think Yeah. What I was trying
to say I Sorry, I was in the middle of doing a Louisis Rosman
bit. If you want to be a [__] you got to be the whole
[__] Okay. You want to be a [__] you
got to be the whole [__] As Louis Rossman always
says, okay,
you want to be a be the whole [__] and actually say
you're a bully. Okay, straight up say that you're a bully. I
hate these people. That is all of these women. They are they
are being that they're real as they're like this guy. Hate this
guy. Yeah, I'm going to watch his [__] Yeah, you
know what? He's suing me. Give me weed money. This I'm not backing
down. Casey Tron is going to spend all of that GoFundMe stuff
on weed money and then just declare bankruptcy. She literally
posted it. She didn't say like, "Oh, this is the Casey Tron defense
money." She said, "Ethan Klein is trying to make it so that I
can't get medical marijuana anymore. Please give me money to
buy weed. There's no way she did that. There's no way she did
that. On Twitter. Let me find. There's no
way that she did that. Hold on. Also, I want to watch this clip
because apparently this is Ethan saying that he wants everybody
reacting to his content everywhere on the internet. Okay, everybody
react everywhere on the internet. All the industrial entrepreneuring
spirits out there. I am opening our IP. Uh Supreme, you don't
have to clear all four pillars. You know that, right? that like
copyright law is the most nebulous law ever made and you can
actually totally violate one of the pillars and sufficiently
pass the other three and it's like totally fine. You can create
a straight up market replacement of something, right? That is
probably the one that you wouldn't it'd be very difficult to
get away with, but if it's transformative enough, right? I linked
you the tweet. Clip you're about to watch is crazy clip chimp.
Literally the next 10 seconds changes it entirely. Okay, send
me the better clip then. To the world, this is a message with
peace and love.
You can now make your own H3 podcast. That's right, everyone.
I guess you That's not what I mean. That's not what I mean. No,
you can't make a fake H3 podcast. Although, you probably could
actually cuz I don't think anyone would mistake it. I mean, if
it's a parody, do whatever you want. I don't think anyone would
mistake it. So, our my our IP is open. I got inspired by Hassan.
He has that the Assan industrial complex. So, I want the Ethan
Industrial Complex. I think it's a good idea. I like it. Yeah,
I think it's really cool. And it's actually crazy how like many
people are are seemingly making a decent living from having their
own clips channels of him. So if you want to cut up clips from
the podcast,
from our members live, from anything with me in it, go for it,
man. Why did the audio cut out here? Did they actually cut out
the part that uh Where's the audio? Clify this. Hold on. Yeah,
where's the where is the audio? He's basically Yeah, I get what
he means. Um, and maybe somebody else is claiming like, "Oh,
people are interpreting this as you can just like rip our whole
video." He clearly says clips over and over. Clips channel clips
from the show. Doesn't say upload the show. Act like you can
misinterpret that. I've used FFmpeg all the time. I've never
had FFmpeg just cut 10 seconds of audio off of the end of a clip.
That's weird. Pull up the tweet. Uh oh. Pull up the tweet. Hold
on. The Casey Tron tweet. Let's check it out. Needs to stand
on business. Ethan Klein is going to sue me for smoking too much
weed. He is trying to take away my ability to purchase my medically
necessary marijuana products. We cannot let this happen. Donate
to my weed fund live on stream now. Let's go. Let's show the
clients how to really goof and gaff.
Why? She got 121,000 views. Why, Casey? Why?
But why?
Why would you do it this way? Why would we do it this way? I
don't get it. Oh, hello. Reuben donated $3. Hello. You could
have a clip channel. Who? We can call it the JSDLK
entertainment workshop. The JSTLK Entertainment Workshop. I love
it. Can't think of any reason that that acronym would be poor.
Okay. J Slke Ew.
Uh, well, JSLK would be the start of the word. So, J E. Yeah.
Supreme, if you want to argue that no React content passes fair
use, then I mean that that's like a totally different. You think
all React content shouldn't be there? I that's probably not like
interesting to argue. I mean, it would be interesting to argue.
It's not interesting to see this is like a different case in
my opinion. Anyway, all right. Okay. Apparently, there's more
there where he says not the whole video. I don't even know what
he says. If anybody wants to actually send me the rest of that
clip instead of just saying that the rest of it like doesn't
count. Oh, Riy did himself. Really? And now you're making it
explicit. Even though Riyle clipped that before, Riyle is willing
to go, "Hey, here's the whole thing." Yeah. The only time I'll
remove something is like if it's just a wholesale re-uploading
of like an episode and we used to have that. Oh, here's another
thing though. Okay, here's why. Make it a clip. Here's why. Denims
and Casey Trron and Froggen are nowhere near as egregious as
any other uploader. It's because when they did that, they did
watch party it and they probably watched it with like a 100 people,
maybe even a thousand people. Okay, but which waiting room are
we in? We're not We're not taking calls right now. We're going
to react to this content. We'll take calls after possibly esports
Batman. But Asmin Gold XQC, these people run YouTube channels.
They compete in your marketplace. Okay, Ethan. How is Ethan suing
when he doesn't even stream on Twitch? Ethan essentially never
streams on Twitch. Ethan is not in the same marketplace that
Denims, Caseyron, and the likes are in. Um,
okay. Hold on one second. I need to uh give me two seconds here.
I'm going to hit play on this. You guys watch for just a little
bit. Give me two seconds. I'll be right back. That big problem
we were on Twitch. If you're up if you're re-uploading just full
VODs, then that that you cannot do. Mhm. If you're you're cutting
highlights. Yes. If you're just re-uploading a video, this stupid
obviously.
Yeah. Yeah. So, uh get out there and start earning people.
There's a clip. Go look for the clip. There's money out there.
Are you going to grab it or are you going to sleep on it for
the clip? The clip clip clip clip clip. Bella Simmons. Another
Bella. Hello. Hello.
We're back. We're back. Okay. I can't remember what I was saying
just now. I'm uh we're trying to clip Jason.
So you were saying so Ethan basically just said what we knew
he didn't say. He said, "Oh, the only thing I'm taking down is
they just like upload an entire episode." which at that point
would not be clipping an episode. And then you said that these
um Denims, Froggen, and the other one, they are like less egregious
than anyone else because even when they're watching it, it's
like to a couple hundred people um or a thousand people. For
some reason, your hero in chat says um he heard 50,000. 50,000
for who? Denims. Maybe maybe denims could get there, but I don't
think nobody else possibly could. They might mean 50,000 for
Denim's.
I don't know. Maybe people go back and watched her Twitch chat
or because people reacted to her Twitch Twitch stream. I can't
imagine she had 50k views. I just So that's the the level of
this market replacement is nothing close to the other things.
And honestly like uh XQC Asmin Gold Hassan even probably not
Hassan in this case but XQC Asmin Gold I guarantee you go look
at their stuff it's not even close to like to like not being
a market replacement right that that's absolutely a market replacement
Denim had 50k live viewers that would be pretty easy to check
though wouldn't it so denim
if um we'll check this real quick we'll check denim solome right
now and we can we can literally find it really quickly and we'll
just we'll just know for Sure. So, she hits 12,000 average on
what in February? February 1st. That could be that's probably
when it was was February 1st. This February 1st stream is what
we're looking for. Feb first.
So, is he literally going to take the moment where there was
peak viewership and imply like he lost 50,000 concurrent viewers
to a video?
Yeah, peak viewership is not the same. See here. So, 43,000 is
where she got up to. She had 5,000. Then she got raided. I'm
guessing. Did she get raided by Hassan? Oh, this looks like a
Hassan raid to me, right? There was a big plan to watch her stream
instead of watching H3 to deny him any views. Okay. No, she was
saying to watch her stream. Yeah, I I I can see that that she
was saying that. Anyway, we should watch the uh the video, guys,
and then we can go through all of the responses and stuff after.
We have not watched the video yet. I think that there are actual
egregious violators of this and and people who are making it
harder for YouTubers to like make a living and none of those
people are Denims or Denims or Casey Tron or Frogan. Certainly
not Casey Tron or Froggen. Okay, maybe you could argue Denims
did some damage. Maybe if like there was a co if there was a
collaborative effort to push all all like leftist streamers to
her. Maybe
Okay. But one more thing I'm gonna ask about. It's the content
of the video. So, is it is it not off for him to select people
who disagree with him politically and only target them for copyright
infringement?
Only his detractors. I mean, I think that's weird personally,
but looking we're looking at people who I actually don't know
if Casey Tran knows what's happening in the Middle East. Um,
but she's friends and supports Froggen and Denims and those two
are they like oppose uh Israel and the IDF. Does not does that
not make this like a messier case for him in court that it could
be. I mean I'm sure a messier case. I'm sure it makes it a I
don't know about pre Maybe they could claim prejudice. I mean
it's also only women, right? I think that's actually the least
of the concern. If they can demonstrate that the the content
was offensive to their political ideology and that he actually
does not have a problem with other people who are uh who agree
with him and their reaction to the content and that he's specifically
targeting them and has been hate targeting them for their political
beliefs
and has directed harassment towards them. Does this not open
him up even more? I mean, it opens him up to those criticisms.
I don't know if it opens up to anything legal. Okay, so uh Supreme
just said I'm this is my last this my last like little debate
thing with chat and then I'm going to jump into the actual Ethan
Klein video, but Supreme says if you're Ethan Klein, you've crusaded
for years against Lazy full replacement React content. You want
to generate precedent to change the shape of YouTube? Which lawsuit
do you take to do that? Asminxc or the people claiming malice
and saying they refuse to act? Uh given that the people claiming
malice are 0.001% 0001%
of all of the actual content on YouTube and all of the popular
react channels are people who don't do full-on like I you sue
me reacts. Although XQC has, by the way, XQC has literally said
this. You sue me if it's a problem, right? So, I would say the
the actual lawsuit you want to do if you wanted any change on
YouTube at all is to sue people who put content on YouTube, which
is none of these. Yeah. Which is why which is literally none
of these. You just said, "Which one do you want to do to affect
change on YouTube?" Uh, probably one against somebody who posts
content on YouTube. Oh my god. I actually just figured out who
is the person he actually needs to sue just to not be a complete
like partisan hack. And whatever,
misogynist, if you want to include that as well, because it's
not XQC.
It's actually Destiny. Destiny literally even shut off his camera
when he watched this video. He just left the room. Wait, no.
They want to show Yes. Yes. He literally just played this video,
left the room. I think he even shut his camera off and just let
the thing go entirely. And I think when he came back, he was
like, "All right, do I have to watch that?" Oh, that'd be very
interesting. That would be very interesting. Listen, I think
I answered your question that time. If I was those girls, I would
bring that up. Yeah, sure. Which lawsuit do you think is easier
and quicker to win? This one. This lawsuit does changes nothing,
though. you said changes the the landscape of YouTube. This lawsuit
changes nothing about what's happening on YouTube. 0%. So that's
that's the issue. But I wonder okay need to watch the video.
I think you never I think you just never pursue this other person
because he's ideologically aligned with you. Sorry. Say that
again. He if um DG of Destiny's community is ideologically aligned
with uh Ethan, they support him, right? I think it just it puts
another like nail in the coffin of he's just going after and
suing people who who do not align with him and his beliefs. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. All right. Hit and play. Hi there. My name
is Ethan Fond and my favorite hobby is spending hundreds of thousands
of dollars on
Although I will think I will say it's a little funny to be like
I'm so rich and then you burn $1 bills. my home. Sorry, my favorite.
If I were a lesser man, an anti-semitic comment would consume
me here and I would have to make it. But I will not, okay? Because
I am a good man who will not do that kind of thing. Okay? I will
not join. I'm trying to walk away. Isn't it illegal to burn money?
I do believe it's illegal to deface US currency. Yes. Yeah. It
has to be. That better be stunt money. Generational wealth for
my attorney. Let me tell you guys a story. about a year and a
half ago. It's a big conversation called ReactGate. Ex Destiny
Orbiter Denims. I do I do
I think Ethan's just better than this, but it's fine. ReactGate
was a debate going on in the streaming community about what constituted
fair use. People like Hassan, XQC, and many of the large Twitch
streamers would watch other creators entire video on their stream.
They would rarely add sufficient commentary. Zoe says fake money.
Okay. Well, even more so, or even pause the video to speak. Most
egregiously, they would re-upload the entire VOD to YouTube with
the same thumbnail, the same title, so that they could traffic
from the original video. Here's what Lemino had to say about
this phenomenon. I don't mind people reacting to my videos, but
I do mind when they play the entirety of my video. A facecam
in the corner or the occasional interruption does nothing to
address that issue. my video is still being played from beginning
to end in someone else's stream or video. It's neither ethical
nor necessary to feature the entirety of someone else's work.
Or, you know, they they could do the bare minimum and ask for
permission. Something that none of the major reaction channels
have ever done when they've streamed or re-uploaded my videos.
But, okay, so we're we're going to pull up Lemo and say that
hey, like you should ask me for permission when reacting. Like
Leo's major issue with a ton of the content that got made was
that they didn't ask permission. They just did these reactions,
right, that he felt were unethical, even if there was a reaction
there, right? Are we going to actually use this criticism in
to inform the video? I want to see to answer your question, no.
I I don't want people to stream or re-upload the entirety of
my
Now, understandably, this made a lot of people angry because
why should these content thiefs essentially get more views than
the author of the video, which in a lot of cases was happening.
I mean, people don't like injustice and this just we all see
this and no, it's not right. This kind of like when a huge huge
creator sues, you know, someone smaller when they give an opinion
for defamation. Nobody likes to see that. Everybody, you know,
that's just that's just injustice. Everybody hates injustice.
debate culminated when XQC, one of the prime suspects, called
in to my show to debate me, in which case I'm sad to report that
I was uh terribly owned. So, in that regard, do you care at all
about like IP or copyright
or like the fact that it's illegal? Does that matter if it that
it might be illegal? Uh, does that matter to you? Uh, no, it
doesn't matter. Well, if flat out doesn't because Well, that's
fair.
Watch me. Oh, that's fair. Is that fair? Doesn't matter. Full
screen can do the warm and watch your watch your planned content
for a week. Do a week of nocont.
XQC went through some good arguments here and then he showed
up to this debate. If you don't remember, I think like 30 hours
into being awake. I don't think he had any sleep. He just showed
up like high on amphetamines with no cognitive process at all.
Like he was just like he was a zombie. Okay. And then that in
the in this zombie-like state, that's where he figured out how
he could win. Okay. He hit the worm. He hit the worm out of nowhere.
Nobody expected it. He made a comeback. He, you know, famously
won this debate by hitting the worm. Okay. How many views you
get? XQC is awesome. Oh, okay. Sure. We call this We call this
the worm. I don't know. This is more like the caterpillar. I
don't know if we call this the worm. Really? This is like a caterpillar.
Inchy squinty. I mean, that's content, man. It's It's original
the ultimate debate bro. He hit him with the worm. Oh, why didn't
I think of that first? I kid XQC, but he is not the one I'm suing.
Despite my criticism, he's not a So, when Muda said this will
change YouTube, he basically meant React streamers are going
to get No, this is not going to react streamers at all. No precedent
you could set here is possibly going after react streamers are
going to change like anything. The the precedent they're going
after the the issue. So maybe this will change throughout the
video, but what's been presented to me is the maliciousness of
these people is what's being attacked here is the is a primary
focus of the lawsuit. Maybe that's maybe that's different, but
we'll we'll see. Malicious infringer, but the ones
you'll see are much much worse. Now, ironically, after this debate
and in the wake of this large conversation, the problem seems
to have only gotten worse. You have people like Hassan paving
the way of fair use with what's known as cherry reacts. When
Hassan gets up to go to the bathroom or to eat or to talk to
his mom or to do whatever, disappears for a extended period of
time and leaves the video playing for his chair. Mr. Chair, they
call it IDF had warned people to leave the area around the main
airport in Sana.
Tiska, if maliciousness is entirely irrelevant,
is Ethan not the height of by posting this video that focuses
entirely on the intent of creators? So, you're saying Ethan Klein
is in fact like a sub50 IQ because intent has nothing to do with
any of this, but he posted a video focusing entirely on the intent
of these creators when they go to take these works. That's interesting.
I personally would have thought you were an Ethan supporter.
I didn't think you'd call Ethan like that, but that's
This operation
for an open and it was in this setting that I formulated an idea.
What if I could make a long form irresistible piece of content
that I knew that these streamers couldn't resist? They couldn't
avoid the temptation of watching it the second it was published.
I don't have Yes. Yes. What if he did that? Oh, does he actually
lay out his intent the entire time? That's awesome.
It's not that I wanted these people to steal my video. It's that
I knew they would. I knew they would. You literally asked them
to many times. Many times you asked them to go and do it. Watch
the entire video, add little to no commentary, react to it instantly,
giving them no time to form an opinion. The trap was set and
it worked even better than I imagined it would. We captured pretty
much every large streamer reacting to it in its entirety immediately
after it was published. Now, the thing is, there were a few people
that went above and beyond to commit copyright infringement.
For example, Denim sits here silently
with nearly 50,000 live viewers. That's 30 times her regular
viewership. She's working directly with the Snark subreddit moderators.
That was for the whole video
to siphon views. Was that for the whole video? Maybe it was for
the whole video. Here's an excerpt from a stickied post from
the Snark subreddit. Hey everyone, we've seen a lot of comments
about wanting to watch the nuke without showing support for H3.
Here's a list of creators who have supported our sub, either
by engaging with us directly or citing our post in their critique
of H3. Here, they're offering these streamers as market. Why?
Hold on. Why? Why is this relevant? Why Why would this be relevant?
This H3 snark post. I don't understand if this is relevant to
a conversation on copyright infringement substitutes for my work.
This is the cardinal sin of copyright infringement. The snark
subreddit has been a frequent and persistent infringer. That's
how I knew when this video came out. Oh. Oh, the clips that get
posted on the snark subreddit are frequent and and persistent
infringement on his copyright. Okay. I don't understand. Is there
no public interest there at all? Snarkers were going to encourage,
promote, and push streamers to commit copyright infringement.
I should thank the Snarkers, actually. Because of their predictability,
they acted like double Asians for us, incriminating their favorite
streamers and serving them up on a golden platter. So, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, hold on. How does this incriminate them?
How does this incriminate these streamers? How does a third party
saying, "Watch these streamers instead of watching Ethan," how
does that incriminate the streamers
What? I'm I've totally Have I missed the boat here entirely?
I I don't understand how this would go. Like the friend of my
enemy is my enemy.
I Yeah, it's it's literally like webbing them together. I don't
understand what the point here would be.
You're reaching Jto. Just watch. I'm literally asking questions.
He's saying you can watch them instead of Ethan, but this is
a third party. Sorry I cut you off there. Yeah, he's trying to
link the fact that like here this subreddit hates me, but they
like these streamers, so these streamers are my enemies. Yeah,
which is like a stupid point to make.
Very
I Hold on. I'm asking questions that are relevant to the video.
I think I think you have to be a complete [__] to
think that this is evidence of wrongdoing on another party's
part. you would have to be very stupid when this subreddit or
the person who posted this thread is not part of the lawsuit.
This is like literally the problem that people have with uh I
think with the Kiwi Farms. It's the idea that like what you're
supposed to like from these sorts of forms is that it could be
somewhere to
um to get an idea of information, but then you should like source
it yourself, like make sure that it's accurate and stuff like
that. So like I think what he means for his snark subreddit is
that oh this is a good a good like place that a logged a lot
of for me so I've been able to go back and like source through
it but you wouldn't say that because they posted it here it means
that these content creators are like doing something to me. Does
that make sense? Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. And not only that, he's
not even saying it's a good s Well, it's funny cuz it could be
a good source, but he's claiming that the clips they posted where
they sourced, like where they linked to things or where they
sourced things from his stream, he's saying that's copyright
infringement in and of itself, which I also think is quite funny.
Oh, really? Yeah, that's what he just said. He just said uh Snark,
which is a a persistent like violator, a persistent copyright
which is uh very interesting. Snark is so he thinks is it copyright
infringement if you just post a clip
depends on how how uh what do you call it how it won't be transformative
but it depends on so there it's like uh some news sites can do
this if it's like uh in the public interest and if it doesn't
serve as a market replacement for the video then you could argue
that it is okay claims that they were posting clips to from his
paywalled content I would say it would depend on how newsworthy
how much it serves a public interest then right but I think with
paywalled content you get into some real problems. He did unfortunately
in that clip say if you take clips from his payw wall content
and post it that he did not have a problem with it. So I would
it would be interesting to see. In any case, uh also with this
this is a message board. So you'd have to separate the people
the individual actors as well. So anyway, we I think we can continue
though. The snarkers actually because of their predictability
they acted like double Asians for us incriminating their favorite
streamers and serving them up on a golden platter. Hold on. Yeah,
but the body of the post basically describes a malicious market
replacement intent. No, it doesn't. Not on behalf of the parties
who are being sued. Obviously,
I need you guys to use, you know, if you got two brain cells
to rub together, we're going to need Sparks here to understand
that. Okay. Yeah, you guys aren't disagreeing. So, the person
who posted this thread absolutely wants Ethan to not make money
off of you guys of anyone viewing that content. And because there's
super anti-fan feels that way, he's going to post and link you
to other content creators that you can watch it through. Uh the
problem will be if those content creators also express the same
thing and they're like, "Watch me instead of watching Ethan."
Sure. But you you can't take this Reddit poster and say that
because the Reddit poster said this, then all of these people
were doing that. These people have to also say it themselves.
Well, hold on. I know that that's where you're going. And to
me, I think that's reasonable if both people let's say let's
say Casey Tron and this Snark subreddit are saying the same things.
Okay.
Is Ethan Klein of all people really going to argue that that
proves that they're in a collusion together? Because then every
single time he's called somebody anti-Semitic for saying he works
with the ADL, he looks really stupid. No, I don't. No, no, no.
I'm I'm agreeing with you. You can't call it a collusion. Even
if there's overlap, it's not a collusion. It is very funny. It
is. Yes, it will be very funny because it's just a a common thing
that people do to sort of throw shade or make it seem like they
are, I don't know, getting one up on you. Yep. Yep. Like this
guy, but we're going to watch it so he doesn't make a bag. It's
corny. He literally answers everything. Just press play. Hey,
if you're not here for our commentary, Revol,
okay, that's literally what this channel is. I don't know if
you thought this channel was just somewhere where we're going
to replay H3's video, his whole video without commenting, but
it's not. That's actually the entire purpose of this channel.
Like,
actually, off. Okay, get the out of here if that's not what you're
here for. So, thank you, Snark. It's one thing for a subreddit
to admit it's engaging in copyright infringement, but how do
you get the streamers themselves to admit that they're stealing
content?
Well guys, uh if you enjoyed um not giving any views to that
terrible video, follow, subscribe, throw a prime if you like
the content, if you enjoyed your time here. It turns out they
just do it for you. You couldn't cook up a more incriminating
statement if you tried. Yeah, you could. I I'm fully intending
to cause harm to Ethan Klein by doing this, and I want to profit
in doing it from the harm done to him. It's not quite that. Denim's
the queen of self-owning. you prevail. Again, there's one thing
about copyright. I believe the other ones are worse than that,
though. You got to register it before you publish to be eligible
for statutory damages and attorneys fees, which is the main biting
force of a copyright infringement lawsuit. Well, I'm happy to
tell you guys now I, Ethan Klein, have registered a content nuke
with the United States Library of Congress. Wow. I wonder who
could have given him that idea. I wonder who could have possibly
said, "Hey, Ethan, you know, you could do statutory damages."
It's almost like somebody came on this stream and threatened
Riyle Kitten House specifically with $150,000
in statutory damages for reposting part of an anything else episode
months and months and months ago. I believe we could even we
could even pinpoint in time because it was actually back when
Wes was on. It's almost like these people might have been talking
to one another.
I think it's very weird to me personally. Personally weird when
when H3 actually comes out, when Ethan comes out and says, "Yes,
I was planning to sue these people. It's been my plan to sue
these people all along." I personally and listen, legally that
doesn't mean he's not able to do it, right? Legally, he still
has every leg to stand on. I'm just saying for me personally,
it's very, very bizarre that he went and registered this with
the express purpose of trying to get statutory damages against
people reacting. and and he's going to say now that these people
helped him and he's only going after these three people. I don't
believe that to be true, but we'll we'll see. We'll see. Some
of you guys out there sweating.
Even though theoretically I could sue a lot more creators and
rake in millions of dollars, but the purpose of this is not financial
gain. People like XQ. Okay, the purpose is not financial gain.
And Asmin Gold may have watched the entire thing, but I would
never. XQC's got a two and a half hour react. How long is the
content nuke?
It sounds like this. This sounds like a weak transformation.
At least Asmin Gold's almost 4 hours. Pursue them just for doing
that. I don't want to chill the reaction community into fear.
Actually, the opposite. I hope that we can all unite against
this type of egregious behavior that not only makes us all look
bad, but could destro
Hold on. We've got We've got somebody Wait. This is a chair react
to Ethan's stream. The The countdown to the content nuke.
Did Denim sit in her chair the whole time? this type of egregious
behavior that not only makes us all look bad, but could destroy
the commentary community as we know it. Well guys, uh if you
enjoyed um not giving any views to that terrible video, follow,
subscribe, throw a prime. The state of reaction content on Twitch
is so broken these creators feel comfortable looking right into
a camera and saying outright, "Hey, I'm stealing this guy's content.
Pay me instead of him." This is not a healthy environment. And
with people like Hassan reacting to entire TV shows on stream,
my fear, wait, why didn't he sue Hassan? That Sony or Disney
comes along, sues everybody and sets a devastating precedent
that could endanger our entire field. Now, before I actually
just sounds like Dan all over again.
Uh, well, there's a reason for that. There's a reason it sounds
kind of like that. Yeah. Where it's almost packaged as if like
I'm doing this for you guys. I'm doing this so our so this streaming
thing so it's safer. Don't you guys care about like platforming
terrorist propaganda? That's actually advertisers are going to
go away. I know I'm emailing them specifically and telling them
to boycott, but like if I didn't do it, somebody was going to
I'm doing it for you guys. Uhhuh. He's doing it for everyone
else. Yeah, they're doing it for everyone else. Yeah. Ethan registered
with the Library of Congress and is showing people a foolproof
way of um attacking one another for other people. Yeah. I mean,
it sounds like basically everybody could do this. Now, I will
say the super high statutory damages up to $150,000 are only
for malicious like like explicitly malicious um violations of
copyright. So, fair use, if you are trying to follow fair use,
you're probably not falling into that where the where the penalties
are super high, right? But he's basically, yeah, showing people
the way where all of these bigger YouTube creators, they might
as well actually all go do this now. Oh, wait. What did Ethan
Klein do? Well, we should all go register like this, right? Well,
how much does it cost to register like this? Um, not that much
money. I forget exactly, but it's not that much. It's like it
might be a a couple hundred bucks at most. It's It's less than
a thousand bucks, which you said 50 bucks. Yeah. Some Oh, okay.
50 bucks is not is not too bad. medium-sized creators could afford
to, I think, copyright their all of their videos for 50. Yeah.
Yeah. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
But like you say, up and cominging creators, I don't think
would take that sort of precaution where they do where they dish
out that $50 for every video because that's like what half of
their editor fees.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Like probably smaller content creators
aren't going to do that. And those are actually probably the
people like you. I don't know if you're making this point, but
Yeah. who need that protection. Yeah, exactly. Cuz it's like
the people who, you know, it's the it's the XQC. The best hypothetical
here is imagine, this is the hypothetical that I really liked
from the actual React drama that happened with XQC was imagine
you have somebody who comes up with an engine design that's incredibly
fuelefficient and Ford while they're negotiating with that person
or before they negotiate with that person, they take that engine
design, they put it in all of their engines, they make billions
of dollars and then like the the penalties that they could even
give back to the person are like poultry, right? that person
could sue them, but it's almost not going to do anything. It's
the smaller person, the smaller creator who's going to get by
the big company who could just go and get sued and not care,
right? Like they're losing out on a bunch of money technically.
Okay. So, I think I think that's how I think of it is imagine
it was like a patent instead of a copyright that that a bigger
company was selling a bunch of products. I I think although although
it doesn't work legally quite the same, I think in terms of how
you should think about it and how you could think of, you know,
how profits should be shared, I it works a little bit. Anyway,
I it's so in in that case, I think that would be good. I don't
think Ethan is helping any of those people here. I don't think
he's actually helping the people who would be hurt by this. So,
it's a little frustrating. I tell you who the three people I'm
suing are. I just want to make it clear that they all met this
very specific high bar of criteria that I set forth earlier.
These people were not targeted based on their gender, their identity,
their political beliefs. All three are on this list. In fact,
they're the only three, as far as I could tell, that reacted
to the full video. Drum roll, please. Who's sweating at home,
guys? Casey Tron, the queen of ripping farts and bongo. They
do musicals. They're very musical people.
Are you being serious? Okay, that Listen, I've already clicked
off of this stream. I'm pretty sure this can't possibly be considered
a market replacement. Okay, I've already clicked off with this
this fat woman ripping bong hits and coughing into her mic. Yeah,
no, that's not a market. It takes a very special unique kind
of human being uh I hesitate to say so human being to watch this
and be like, "Yeah, I'm going to watch this instead of just finding
this video on YouTube." For sure, dog. What do you look You think
I made incredibly transformative.
Froggen, who bless her soul, she's still rising. Can I use a
Can I walk away and use the bathroom? Do I have permission? Can
I can I use the bathroom, please? I'll leave it playing. I hope
there's more here from We'll see. Apparently thinks Twitch is
liable for me interviewing a Yemen teenager who's only known
genocide his entire life. And Denim's the queen of selfowning.
And my god, is she the queen of that?
Uh, Supreme, I think it's wrong. Absolutely. I just don't think
it's effective in this case. That's all. I don't think anybody
who's watching through these people was going to watch it through
e Ethan Klein's like YouTube channel. I think they would explicitly
do it. Yeah, it's very obvious from the way that guy's talking.
He's a Sneo fan. Oh my god, bro. I love you. Can I give you a
hug, bro? I'm so sweaty, bro. I love you, bro. None of the hostages
that have been released so far have said that they have been
the hostages have public statements. You can go look at them.
This assault I experienced should never happen to any human being.
This Yemen kid is just a Yemeni kid with a gun and is not a Houthi
and there is no proof of him being a Houthi. Are you a soldier?
Yes. That seems pretty definitive. He never said Hassan.
It's not definitive. He's literally a social media influencer.
It's not definitive at all.
That kid, that kid is almost certainly not a like Yemeni soldier
in any way. And yes, he might have said so in a Tik Tok comment.
It's not remotely definitive. Okay. Hassan says he's a journalist.
Who thinks Hassan is a journalist? Low is a good guy. I do. I
can't believe I'm calling those days. I mean, listen. Now for
the fun part. Let's take a look at the complaints. And let's
start with my favorite of the three, the very own, the prestigious,
the highly acclaimed, the highly analytical
Casey Tron. Oh, just are we going to quickly are we going to
quickly throw Casey's docs in here? Make sure we get her full
name in here. I've been wanting to watch this. Nice. Without
necessarily supporting Ethan Klein.
So, we're going to watch it. Well, that's a really dumb thing
to say, don't you think? He dances with the Houthy hostages as
well. Oh, Scumi Fiend, give me the clip, Scuba Fiend, give me
the clip. Okay, you got 10 minutes to find me the clip of that
kid dancing with the hostages. Okay, 10 minutes or I'm going
to have to let you off for the rest of the night. Why are you
so comfortable? We've Sure. Rewinding a little bit. Wait, how
much? Not that much. Just to what Casey says. A lot of people
have been wanting to watch this
without necessarily supporting Ethan Klein,
so we're gonna watch it. Well, that's a really dumb thing to
say, don't you think? Why are you so comfortable? We've given
each complaint a clever little title. And here's Casey Trrons.
She smoked more than she spoke. Casey Trron smokes 42 times during
her reaction. And just as a silly thought experiment, we thought,
wouldn't it be funny if she spent more time smoking than she
did talking and thinking there was no way that that could be
true. Uh Ethan cleverly revealing to everybody this is a virtue
signal. Okay, cleverly Ethan has revealed to everybody that he's
never watched a Caseyron stream before. Okay, he he actually
is sitting here and he's like, you know what, there's no way
Caseyron could have possibly smoked more than she spoke.
No idea. Is that like is what she said incriminating enough where
she's acknowledging like um what would you say like a market
for something? She said there's a lot of people who want to watch
this without supporting Ethan.
Oh no, that is Hold on. That can't possibly be considered creating
a market replacement, right? Cuz she's acknowledging that there
is a market outside of him that she's trying to There's Yes,
there is. And that is obviously true that there would be a market
of people who would not watch this via him at all, who would
refuse. And the fact that she would tell her stream that it's
not like she's telling her stream, "Hey, don't watch Ethan. We're
gonna watch this." She's like, "Um, there's people who want to
watch this without like supporting Ethan, so I'm gonna You know
what? That's such a good point, Supreme. Good. That you really
you really got me with that one. This argument is so stupid.
That was an amazing argument right back. That wasn't stupid at
all. Hold on. There's a whole bunch of people here who are pretending
that they would just like watch Tommy C. How many of you guys
watch Tommy C's content? Can I get a can I get a show of hands
in chat? Uh, put a one in the chat. If you watch Tommy C on your
own and don't just see him through me. Oh, is that like nobody?
Okay, so when I go and talk Tommy C, am I creating a market replacement
for his content? I've watched a whole bunch of Tommy C content
over the past week, I don't feel like I've created a market replacement
for it at all. Why are people so like it's it's very possible
to just say this seems interesting or is this definitive or is
this wrong? Why you got to be such a debate pervert?
Just like move on. Just keep going. Sure. Well, we tallied them
up and lo and this is basically there the argument is obviously
somewhere in the middle but it's obviously not you're guaranteed
creating a market replacement by providing an alternative to
this at a lower price point or something like that. Right there
there there isn't a guarantee there. This is the argument that
really really silly game company lawyers make when they say,
"Well, there's pirated like uh this many times, so we lost out
on that many times times the market price of the the software,
that much revenue." No, you didn't. No, you didn't. No, you didn't.
And we can all we can all understand that argument, right? You
clearly didn't lose out on that much revenue. Behold, there's
15 minutes 40 seconds of commentary verse 18 minutes and 55 seconds
of smoking. She spent 3 minutes and 15 seconds longer smoking
than she did talking in her quote unquote reaction. And whatever
talking she did was just to express how confused she was, presumably
from smoking 42 times. What is happening? I'm trying to follow.
I've lost the plot. The complaint continues. Indeed, Casey Tron
is often too obliterated to comment on the nuke and instead stares
blankly. Guys, guys, I've heard, you know, I've just heard in
the past that apparently legal documents can't be written like
this. This seems really unprofessional, doesn't it? Don't they
understand that a legal document is invalid if you speak colloquially
in it? If you if you say Caseyron's obliterated, that's like
not professional or or legalistic speak at all? That that's doesn't
don't they know? I think it's immediately invalid if you use
language like this. I've heard. Could you imagine if they use
the word gaslighting in here? My god. at her computer screen.
In a span of two hours and seven minutes, Casey Tron smokes marijuana
frequently in highly concentrated forms through vaporizers on
42 separate occasions. At one point, Casey is so wasted that
she every time Supreme like types. Okay. I I don't That's for
the courts to evaluate, not the lawyers. What the What is he
saying? Um he's saying who the communicates to the courts? I
just I don't like this guy. Go on with the video. What is happening?
I'm trying to follow, but I've lost the plot. To give you an
idea, the majority of her commentary comes down to this. I don't
understand this bit that he's doing. He's read more books than
you could ever imagine. CPM coming out of anime, right? I'm not
inviting people on stream right now. We're literally going through
the video. Okay. It's commentary right now and then we will have
discussions later. He's read more books. Why? Why is Casey Tron
just censored out than you could ever
What is happening? I'm trying to follow. I've lost the plot.
Oh, because she's doing drugs. I see it.
They do musicals. They're very musical
Are you being serious, dog? What do you look You think I made
this
[__] This isn't a music video, Assassan. And as dumb
as all of that is, this is the part that really got her sued.
A lot of people have been wanting to watch this
without necessarily supporting Ethan Klein. Without necessarily
supporting Ethan Klein.
So, we're going to watch it. What the is going on here?
I listen from Casey's lawyers. She's dead to rights with that
statement. Necessarily.
Necessarily.
I'm telling you that that that hedge might actually save her
bacon. Okay. Stating outright that her intention of doing this
is so that people who don't want to support me can watch it through
her is why copyright infringement laws exist. You could not and
should not do that, especially if your commentary consists of
you taking bongloads. At least try to engage with the content.
Whoa, whoa, what was that? Hold on. Oh, sorry. That was a flying
start. Oh. Uh, pour some salt on me. You can come in after. You're
banned until you join the Discord. But listen, you you hop in
one of the VC channels. You're banned until you hop in. But I'm
also not taking calls until the end of this video. So, good luck.
Bye. Almost got me. You know her and you love her, guys.
Froggen reaction by exiting. Here she is getting up to leave
the video running as she steps out of the room. Is that transformative?
Hm. I guess the judge will decide. She said, quote, "It's time
to watch the new Nuke ethically. Hell yeah. Huh. Very smart to
say on camera, by the way. She said, quote, "Thank you guys so
much. I do appreciate everyone's support and thank you for watching."
Oh, they're kind of stretching on the Frogen one. I can understand
maybe uh arguing on the denims one. We'll see if you with me.
Well, you are. So, we'll see if we have better better examples
of Froen's actual malice. Welcome. And I'm so glad that you were
able to enjoy that day. Her commentary is so non-existent that
even her own fans begin to call her out. Do I have anything to
say, dude? because he's cycling the same points over and over
again. What more what more commentary do you need on him repeating
the same points for the whole hour first hour and 30 hour hour
1 minute and 32 seconds? It's been the same [__]
over and over again. This video could have been condensed into
20 [__] minutes. Like what what commentary do you
want me to add by like, "Oh, this guy's a [__] idiot.
He's mentally ill and he's having a mental breakdown and uploaded
it to [__] YouTube." I'm going to make one good point.
What do you want me to make a point on? Oh, I forgot. She also
said, "Can I use the bathroom, please? I'll leave it playing."
You may use the bathroom, Froggen, although I don't advise it.
"Can I can I use the bathroom, please? I'll leave it playing."
This into your stomach. And let me state the obvious. Jew and
apparently thinks Twitch is liable for me interviewing a Yemen
teenager who's only known genocide his entire Oh, what is she
going to say when she comes back?
Well, you just pause it. That's it. You just pause the video,
right? Like, you get up and you go to the bathroom. You do you
just pause it. They should be watching for you. But if you get
up to go to the bathroom and they keep watching my video, they're
I just keep my headphones on and then I pause when I come back
and comment on the thing that was happening. Clearly not watching
for you, right? As lazy and pathetic as her reaction, this is
not why she's getting sued. This is Thank you guys so much. I
do appreciate everyone's support and thank you for watching it
with me. First time viewer. Time to watch a nuke nuke ethically.
Hell yeah. I found my way from Reddit. Hi guys. Welcome Reddit
people. Reddit people. Reddit people. I came from the H3 star
credit. Listen, I understand broken here, okay? I don't care
where my new viewers come from. I'm just happy you're here, okay?
You come from You come from H3. Wait, 4K.
Wait, is her being happy about it proof of something?
That wasn't what Frogan was doing. Wait,
Oh, sorry. I should stop reading chat. You guys are You guys
can just come in and argue after Japan and bother having a great
time. Exactly.
We're going to watch it live. Yes. He doesn't want people to
know when it's dropping cuz we're all watching through other
streamers. And I suggest you all watch it through other people
as well. It's the stated malicious intent to steal. They talk
about watching ethically, but I learned not to steal when I was
five. Up next is Denims. And honestly, just take a look at this
guy. By the way, I also don't know if this is during the video,
but I totally disavow this by the way. I like don't I don't like
doing this. I have a hard time even watching other live streamers
while they're live. I usually go back, if I'm watching a live
streamer, I'll go to their VOD, I'll run it back five minutes
or 10 minutes and say, "If you want to watch this live, go watch
their their stream." Right? So, I like disavow this. I think
it's really behavior.
I don't know if I agree with you suing people and then only suing
people who are like rising to a certain level and are also your
enemies. Okay. Yeah. I think it's the it's so obvious that these
three women put off like the entirety of the internet. I don't
know how I feel about um the fact that other people aren't as
offensive when they do it or that do you have to prove like malice
like he's doing with these clips?
Is that part necessary? Cuz I feel like if they are if it's somebody
with so much more reach than these people, but all they did was
like stand up and walk away for like 30 minutes,
doesn't that do more harm than Krogan telling like 40 of her
viewers, don't watch it. Don't abort him. Um, yeah. No, it absolutely
does. Right. And from what I'm understanding, Malice is not a
part of, as as be very vicious just said, Malice is not a part
of the four pillars of fair use, right?
and and creating a market replacement. I would say if you aligned
with Ethan Klein on on viewership, if if your viewers agreed
with Ethan Klein were more inclined to watch his video on their
own, I'd say that's far more likely to create a market replacement.
Now, is that a legal argument you can make? I don't know. But
it seems like I I'm guessing that if we actually looked into
this at all, these people are not the primary offenders in terms
of harming Ethan's copyright. No, but would you say the way that
he's trying to present it that because they are the rudest offenders,
like he's almost trying to make it seem like it that it's just
for him to go after them because of
Um, well, and then for Denims, I would say also because she's
like, we're like Ethan Klein. Don't watch him. Right. Well, that's
Denims and Frogan. They say that, right? Well, Froggen. Froggen
said you guys should watch through other creators or something,
but it didn't seem like she was saying we're doing it here so
you don't watch it through him. She didn't say it explicitly
from what I saw, but maybe maybe I could have missed it, too.
Well, just right there, she said like, "Oh, he's not saying when
it's going to go live because he doesn't want people to like
plan to watch it off of his channel." Yep. But you guys should
watch it like through someone else. She's kind of like doing
the same thing as Denims. I think Malice isn't part of Oh, go.
No, go ahead. Who are you reading? I was reading uh I was reading
uh Dung Devil's comment here. Malice isn't a part of uh part
of fair use, but malice is the motivator for creating a market
replacement element. Sure, but you have to evaluate how much
of a market replacement it created, right? That's what you have
to actually evaluate here. And oh, there's one other point there.
Malice is also it will be a part of statutory damages. It is
actually important for because Ethan registered it with the Library
of Congress immediately before it was released. Malice is a factor
there where if you are intentionally maliciously violating the
copyright that is the requirement to to seek statutory damages
instead of actual damages. So that that is why the malice part
is important for these people because he has done the special
thing where before he released the video he knew he was going
to want to sue content creators who are going to watch the video.
That was his goal in releasing the video was to sue people watching
the video. Right? That is that is an explicit goal he had as
he said, you know, that's why he delayed I think it's very likely
that that's why he delayed the release because he was waiting
for his copyright to come through. Right. Yes, that does make
sense. I think the the thing that bothers me is I believe in
this situation, the way that it does hurt um help other content
creators, the way what Ethan is doing, how it could actually
help other content creators is to not make it so that people
have to be able to like so obviously be viewed as bullies, right?
Cuz I think for the most part, no one's going to so obviously
do these things. Like these three female streamers are very unique
in playing this role of like the aggressor or the talker. I think
most people who will take advantage of someone else's content,
they're not this egregious while doing so, which makes it very
hard for others to care, right? What was the whole situation
with the person who felt like XQC should have like shouted him
out or something? Let me know because Yeah.
Oh, no, it wasn't Leo. I don't know. It was some It was someone
else because And I think it was with Hassan.
I don't think Oh, no. There was somebody with XQC2, but I can't
remember the name. It was and you could see he got somewhat of
a bump in his like activity on on YouTube, but the guy just felt
like he would want he would have wanted like a little bit more
from XQC, but no one can actually look at XQC and think, "Oh,
yeah, that guy didn't shout him out enough. He didn't he should
maybe should have linked the video. Maybe should have done this."
But you didn't see XQC saying this guy, watch it through me.
Like I don't think you actually help anybody by demonstrating,
oh look, these are bullies and that's why you can get them for
DMCA. Yeah. I mean, as I think as we've gone over, like obviously,
yes. And I I believe it's explicit that in the the fair use things,
it it doesn't matter with the um with regards to intent. So yeah,
it it it literally doesn't matter. And I would say given that
it makes if you want to change things, it makes less sense to
go after these people. I think that's your broad point, right?
Like it it makes less sense to go after them because it shouldn't
matter their belief. This is so clearly for personal grudge.
This doesn't help anybody else. Nobody else is going to have
this like comically theatrical version of, you know, taking down
somebody. Um, so Be very vivic said these are the most slam dunk
cases in the Hassan Orbiter Clipper complex. They're just slamown
cases, but nobody operates like this most of the time. Be very
vivic. This is not how like the the actual thing he identified
was his problem. The react problem he identified, none of these
people participate in it. You understand that, right? The core
issue is people creating market replacements on YouTube. Similar
thumbnails, similar titles. He described his core issue, what
his problem always was. It was XQC taking content from people,
putting a similar title, similar thumbnail on it, and benefiting
and profiting from that problem. Yeah. In a way that other people
can't even notice. No, I just want to make it clear that this
is not the soap box Ethan's been standing on. This is a totally
different soap box that he's going after these people over. It
is not the same. It is not the same at all. The thing he was
trying to do before was to go after Sorry. The thing he was trying
to do without going legally was to go after people who were actually
creating market replacements on YouTube. None of none of these
people are a part of So he tried to connect this to the issue
he had before. It is not connected, right? Yeah, it's not connected.
So it is Yes. aka 11 RA. Why why don't you just like make a normal
name that people can like say out loud? There's it's there's
he obviously has a case here, but it's not the case that he claimed
he was going down this road for. It's not the the hill he's claimed
he would die on for like what over a year now, two years or something.
Yeah, exactly. Thank you for reiterating reiterating. But yes,
this is and I I would question anybody who thinks it is because
again, all of this had to do with YouTube. I was a big I like
I participated in this. I had a lot of discussions around it.
I remember it was two summers ago, right? I remember all of the
conversations I had around this. I had so many conversations
around this. It all had to do with YouTube. Uh in fact, a big
part of Ethan's arguments and the Turkey arguments were, "Oh,
you you actually are like going to the store and you're on the
same shelf with everybody else, right?" These people are not
on the same shelf with Ethan at all. Anyway, we uh we continue.
We can continue. Guys, it's a nightmare on Denim Street. Not
only did Are you saying that you believe the intention of Ethan
to make the content nuke was to set up Denims, Froggen, and Caseyron
for a lawsuit? Uh, I believe that it was a large part of his
intention when making it. Yes. Yes. And that he delayed the release
of it to possibly to possibly allow himself to sue these people.
That he didn't want to release it before he had his copyright
in place because he wanted to be able to sue these people. Did
she cherry? But she was kind enough to I need none of you to
defend that you know what the the name AK11R
is. Okay, that person is even subbed. You guys are disgusting.
to write her name right at the top just so that we knew that
she was stealing my content and it was her room and nobody else's.
Judge, did you know that we're on Denim's street right now? Here's
some quotes from Denims. We're relying on you to stay live so
we don't have to give the nuke views. Yeah, I'm going to stream
it since he's confirmed it's coming out today. I'm going to stream
it. That is very explicit. Denim said, quote, "Well guys, if
you enjoyed not giving any views to that terrible video, give
me a follow, subscribe, throw a prime if you like my content."
Your content. The queen of self-own included a countdown timer
so we could tell exactly how long she was away. After being gone
for a few minutes, she returns and then sits silently for another
couple of minutes eating. I'm going to go pee and hopefully uh
uh when I'm back they're done with this. Obviously, the other
thing that would go along with this is did Ethan attempt to
so so I think showing that he copyrighted this and if Ethan has
communicate let's say Ethan has communications with certain people
hypothetically certain people saying he plans to sue these people
before it comes out right let's say he hypothetically wrote in
some email or some discord chat that he planned to sue these
people who reacted especially if they maliciously reacted okay
and then he made no effort to DMCA that content how would that
look in a in a legal case when you take no efforts when you explicitly
take no efforts when you are possibly taking cues from somebody
who said they don't want to DMCA because they want to uh try
to get statutory damages. I wonder how that would look in a court
of law. It'd be very interesting to me. Yeah, I see what you
mean. Yeah, I I think that would be very interesting. It was
live stream. Wait, wait, wait. Are you Are you claiming Karate
Moses that you cannot DMCA live stream content on Twitch? That
would be a really weird thing to claim. Five. I see it. Dude,
you should do this. I have an alternate. We're relying on you
to stay live so we don't give more views on the nuke. Yeah, I'm
gonna I'm gonna stream it since he confirmed it's coming out
today. We're going to stream it. If you want to watch it, watch
it with someone else who's already watching it. You know, come
enjoy the watch party somewhere else. If you enjoyed um not giving
any views to that terrible video, follow, subscribe, throw a
prime if you like. I I think this is basically like uh like morally
totally morally wrong behavior. You shouldn't you shouldn't do
this with other creator stuff. You should be able to see that
your creator you rely on other people not just rebroadcasting
you, right? Like obviously obviously this is the case. It's super
stupid to do. I hate it. I hate people you don't like. Like you
do not have to be this. You don't you cannot like somebody and
also
just like be a human
and be considerate. That's very possible. It actually feels better.
Well, I I think you should just be you should take a long view
as a content creator and just say like why where do I like what
leg will I have to stand on if somebody just starts rebroadcasting
my content? What leg will I have to stand on? I will have no
moral leg to stand on at all because I've done this. Not even
that. They start having more respect for you when you can dislike
them but still, you know, not go that far to be an act like a
normal person. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Like the content if you enjoyed
your time here cuz I'm going to be honest, I did not want to
watch that by myself. Let me also commercialize it by asking
you to reward me financially for stealing his content. That is
like chef kiss. By the way, Denims had a very successful stream.
She had 43,000 people watching her live. Take a look at the title
of her Twitch stream. Ethan Klein Hassan Content Nuke watch party.
A watch party? I don't think that's fair use. Now, Denim's of
course always delivering the goods. She went on this dude's podcast
to debate fair use. And would you be surprised if I told you
she said a lot of incriminating things in that podcast? The queen
of self never disappoints. I want to be clear on my opinion on
like filler content and stuff. Like I think filler content like
you shouldn't do it. I know I do it as a react stream and I try
to do it only when I do it with like Vox videos or Vice videos
and stuff like that because at least I'm not like directly ripping
from one content creator and not like a whole most of those videos
have like 5 million views. I only get like 500 viewers like like
oh what I'm taking maybe 50 views from the video. It's a lot
harder to feel like I guess bad about that whereas like I would
feel very bad about doing that to like a single content creator.
The majority of people say that they literally wouldn't watch
Hell's Kitchen unless I was streaming it. And it doesn't necessarily
mean that I'm reacting hard enough. You know, I'm sure if you
click on a random part in the video, I might not be saying anything.
Sure, whatever. And I might walk away from the screen, but it's
about like the communal thing. It's why like toast started streaming
uh Death Note. It's not about the actual show. This clip is taken
from Chud, by the way. Oh. Oh, right, right, right, right. Cuz
this is JX, right? Right here. Yeah. The same reason you watch
shows with your friends. You want to watch it with other people.
Oh, is Chud is Chudlogic credited for this clip? A lot of people
go to watch streamers on Twitch for their react content almost
as a curator. So, they don't actually want to go through YouTube
themselves and watch a bunch of videos. And they probably never
will go through YouTube and click a bunch of videos. They like
going to Twitch because they like to have it as like this streamer
is curating fun content that I want to watch. From the people
that I've talked to, not fair. It just keeps saying not fair
use, but that's not an argument. That the entire argument is
about whether the market replacement is created, right? That's
the that's the entire argument.
But what she's saying here talking about like, oh, streamers,
they're just for curated. Like people go and watch streamers
so they don't have to scroll through YouTube themselves. That's
not true. Streamers are I would give you if you said streamers
are like babysitters. Um, but they're not just like a replacement
for scrolling through YouTube and picking videos to watch. Yeah,
I agree. It's like a different thing. Obviously, the community
participation is totally different thing, right? A live stream
is so much different than a video. Obviously
people who watch Twitch content are Oh, then I misunderstood.
She's saying a streamer is or chatters is a curator for YouTube
content.
Like so individual chatters don't have to go and find each YouTube
to watch. They can watch a streamer and hopefully the streamer
has like a good YouTube algorithm or something. YouTuber, this
um streamer knows uh what they should watch today. They're like
up to date or they've got like information on like drama or gossip
that they will uh curate to me. Sure. That's a poor argument.
Obviously, a very poor argument, but I think um she Sorry, she
had just made the community one like before that, right? She
had just made the community one right before this. Yeah, that's
what I was was sticking in my head. But all right, anyway, we
are specifically there to watch it so they don't have to scroll
through YouTube and find a video they like. If someone watches
content, I already said this. If someone watches content on someone
else's stream, there is a very low likelihood that they're going
to go watch it separately and give you like the view or the like
or the people who are watching content on Twitch, curated Twitch
content on Twitch, aren't necessarily people that would be watching
content on YouTube. That my friend is um called theft and you're
a thief and now I'm suing you. This is just a testimony to how
brazen and how safe they've, you know, gotten that she thinks
she can go on a out wants to see. Also, we'll watch that clip
shortly after this public on video and say like, "I'm stealing
this content because I want to. I'm coping even though I know
it's stealing. Um, when people watch it with me, they're definitely
not going to go watch the original." Like, you are way too comfortable
committing crimes out in the open. Well, there you have it. three
separate lawsuits for three separate geniuses. Now, I want to
make it clear again,
and I hope it's been obvious about why I'm suing these three
people and not others. These people not only violated all the
principles of fair use, they also did it maliciously. And that's
the part that really got me. I think if you're a reactor on Twitch,
for the most part, if you make a good faith effort to comment,
and if you make a good faith effort to promote the author, to
link to them, to try to drive traffic to the original, has Ethan
considered that like, okay, I don't think this could possibly
set a precedent, but what if it does set a precedent that up
the entirety of like reaction content and makes it so that basically
it's all totally chilled. Is that something Ethan would be happy
about? Maybe it would be. I would I would be concerned, I guess,
uh, on what what the outcome would be, and I hope would hope
if he's going to say, "Well, this is what I want to preserve.
I I don't know if he cares."
Okay. I think it should be entirely valid that nobody reream
your uh, live broadcast of the video. So, when a YouTube video
premieres, the idea that the streamers sat around waiting for
that, they didn't know when it was going to happen, but they
knew that they wanted to uh yink the live premiere, that I think
is up and that should not
right? Because absolutely, regardless of what Denims is saying
right now, oh, they will never watch it on their own without
me. That's not true. these, they will watch the same video like
eight times in the span of a week because they want to see every
content creator that they're invested in that they like to follow.
They want to see their reaction to it. They want to see their
point of view. They want to see their stupid input, right? It's
not the idea that they'll never watch the other one. It's they
literally care about every individual character in this like
little universe. And that's cool.
Yeah. So, wait, which side do you think that goes on? Do you
think that's like, oh, it's not a market replacement because
they will still watch it or Okay, go ahead. So, I think that
supports both of these people. The idea that I don't believe
them reacting to it is a market replacement except for the fact
that they stuck around and literally yonked the live premiere.
So, for that, I think Ethan has a point. Why' you take the live
premiere
with Yeah, I understand malicious intent. Other law isn't a problem.
Like, I can see that. I can see why he'd be off at this, right?
Like it makes total sense why you be off at these people doing
this.
Yeah. Okay. Video. I think you're probably pretty much doing
the right thing and that's fine. And I would never sue someone
for that. Take it to these three absolute morons to state their
intention to steal my property on video. Be very vivic. That
is not a Sorry, I have to I have to That is not a tie to the
H3 Stark subreddit. Them saying go watch Frogan then Frogan saying,
"Oh, welcome from that subreddit." That's not a proof of a tie.
That's not a tie. That's not a tie. that there's no coordination
or collusion going on there. That's two separate things happening
that happen to seem like they're close together. Unless you want
to admit that Ethan Klein has worked viciferously with the ADL.
I don't know why I said viciferously. He's worked very closely
with the ADL. Okay. What about the opposite? What about the the
content creators
playing into the anti fans? Cuz wasn't that a dynamic with one
of uh Ethan's employees? What is it? one of his his employees
started streaming himself and he was like completely oh AB just
yeah he whatever the snarkers wanted he started doing and playing
into like the the hate that they were um like typing in his chat
and just like conceding everything to them like he lost his own
identity it felt like a couple times to what they wanted and
that might be me reading into it cuz he kind of sat in a tub
while talking directly to them.
Yeah. But either way, like do you not see Casey Tron and what
she said? Like, oh, there are people who are looking for like
a way to watch this without watching it through Ethan is that
to me could be received as she's playing literally into this
anti-fan subreddit because there's like a viewership there. Oh,
wait. Her I thought it was AB that did it. No, no, I'm saying
AB did it. I'm just using that as an example that we've seen.
Okay. Right. Sure. And so the dynamic does happen where like
if you see that there's an an audience that you play into what
they're looking for because they will boost you or they give
you attention, validation, all of that, right? Mhm. Yep. I imagine
that's the only reason why AB was in a tub talking to them because
there's something that he gets out of engaging with them. Um
so maybe like they're not
I don't know. I I feel like the subreddit maybe it's not a coordination,
but the subreddit has an influence possibly. It does. Oh, it
absolutely has an influence, but I would say that's mostly on
the subreddit itself in my opinion. Okay. Like like yeah, I I
think it would be like it has an influence. I just think probably
what you'd need to show an actual tie and blame them for it is
one, you need the subreddit, the poster, to be part of the lawsuit,
and two, I think you would I think you would have to show some
level of coordination beforehand, not just something that like
happens to go together. Like there are subreddits for content
creators or for like celebrities and if if let's say there's
a there's a Harry Potter subreddit is JK Rowling like actually
if if if if they track her book signings and she gets a whole
bunch of people at a book signing makes extra money or hits some
bonus but she had no coordination with them and she thanks the
subreddit for supporting her. Is that like collusion? I don't
think it's collusion. I think it's two things happen to happen
and she's like thanking people for supporting her. I think it's
like basically the same thing like that subreddit has an interest.
The interests happen to align. It doesn't necessarily mean they
go together. I don't even mind people like thinking they work
together, but like I just think you'd have to prove that in terms
of a litigation.
Yeah. You're saying that he can't take these individual streamers
and like use them as a proxy of going after the subreddit. Yes,
exactly. Gotcha. Uh, also I have to go to the bathroom super
badly. So, I'm going to let the I'm going to let the last 30
seconds play where he's doing this and then it's all you for
like two minutes. I need to get some water as well. I'll be right
back. I'll be right back. You know, and to all the detractors
who are saying that I'm targeting women, that I'm a hypocrite
for suing for copyright infringement, I just have this to say.
I don't care. What I do hope though is that you'll support their
crowdfunding efforts to defend themselves because let's face
it, I want to make sure there's money left over for me when I
win my lawsuits. Thanks for watching everybody. It's been a great
time. I'll see you around. Why do why do they do this? Um, let
me just point out everything that could possibly be criticized
about me and just like lean back and be like, I don't care. Are
you going to call me because I'm just going after women? I don't
care. You do care.
You care so much. No like serious person wants to be seen as
a misogynist or or just targeting
hate towards women. You say the same thing about white women.
Do you genuinely think I hate white women? There are no serious
people. possibly. But I I don't think that you can have all of
the opinions that Ethan has and then be like, "Oh, no. I'm just
like a meme lord." Am I dying on the hill of I think Hassan is
a terrorist and I am actually like super invested in the outcomes
of this uh conflict in the Middle East. Um or am I just like
a meme lord? Like I don't think you get to wear both. I What's
the idiom here? Wear both suits, both masks. Oh, hats. Wear both
hats. All right. I am very back. Okay. I don't know. I don't
know if we're quite getting into watching like uh sorry, getting
into watching. Sorry. Getting into discussions yet. I do want
to actually go over the lawsuits themselves. So, let's look at
the uh the Denims one first there. Oh, there's the Dems one.
Also, just to show uh these aren't the only places. What the
hell? Why' that happen? One second. These aren't the only videos
that they can sue over. Okay. Really? Hold on. I have to I have
to re look this up because apparently you get a session with
the Library of
Okay, these aren't the only things they can sue for. So I believe
for Denims, depending on her walking away, I wouldn't be shocked
if they sued twice. So with Countdown to Doomsday and Content
New Cas, I believe Denims would have violated both of these copyrights.
Okay, this for Ted Entertainment Incorporated Content New Casan.
This was uh these were both registered I believe on January 1st
or sorry, January 28th. See, January 28th. Uh oh, March March
31st. Oh, this was done quite a bit after. I wonder why this
was done so much after. Oh, Countdown to Doomsday. Was that the
Idubbbz one? That might be Idubbbz stuff. Actually, I will never
forgive Hassan for this this February. Okay. So, he can he can
basically sue for each of these each of these content each of
these pieces of content that was uh maliciously violated in any
way. He can sue people for statutory damages on any of them.
Can you cover So, this is what uh so somebody made this point.
Oh, can you cover Destiny's coverage of the video? It's insane.
DG literally reream Hassan streams to not give him views. Oh,
I know they do that. Yeah. I mean, they'd have no moral ground
to stand on. They they reream my stream. Uh yeah, I want Jay
Talk's take on whether or not he thinks Ethan is a misogynist.
Um, not like a overt like serious misogynist. He's more like
a accidental like he's got like what would you call it? Like
latent misogyny. He will say misogynist things because of where
he was where when he was brought up. I don't think he's like
overtly I hate women or anything along those lines. I think he
suffers from the same thing anybody else suffers from. They've
been celebrated so long on the internet and they receive so much
criticism. You just like you've got anger built up and you want
to say some [__] to people. Like there are some people
who provoke the misogyny out of you but it's not like you're
actual misogynist, right? It's like you know that they're upset
by the misogyny, so you'll say it. Yeah. And you know that they
are
never mind. I can't do that. No. Okay. All right. So what where
should we go from here? Yes, I have talked with the Library of
Congress stuff. Yes, that is like it's it's proof. But Ethan
literally said, "Hey, yeah, I'm trying to sue these people or
whatever, or I registered it to sue these people, right?" Um,
it is interesting that he's only going after these three. I think
these are the three he can get away with suing, to be honest
with you. I think even if it was less egregious than it is, and
it is pretty egregious, even if it was less egregious, he could
get away with going after these people, right? These people are
broadly hated by everybody who likes him. Um, there's just there's
it's total overlap with like the people he likes. So, there's
just no there's no downside to doing this for him. He won't lose
any viewers. It only hurts the people who already hate him, right?
You see the way he talked about Hassan's 12-hour reaction, Ethan
sounded upset. Ethan almost certainly was upset. I do wonder
if Hassan was tipped off in some way, to be honest with you,
cuz Hassan wouldn't watch it, wouldn't watch it, wouldn't watch
it, and then when he did watch it, it was like a massive obviously
um transformative reaction. So, it was a little funny. Also,
I believe Hassan's lack of pursu lack of watching this is the
reason he waited so long to file these lawsuits, right? I think
that's pretty clear. Is that not pretty clear to everybody that
he was trying to wait until Hassan would react to it? Ethan also
invited him to watch it. He did. He did just sit back and hate
on Doro when he blows Ethan for it. I I don't know if I can hate
like basically Oh, how would I put this? I think Nicholas has
to defend this, right? I think he has to defend this because
it's like pretty consistent with most of the stuff he's been
talking about. Like most of the stuff he he cares about. I also
think he would have taken Ethan's side on the previous reaction
drama thing. I feel like he was so he was pretty levelheaded.
He was pretty based when it came to the whole Twitch ads thing.
They obviously he's not like a fan of Hassan, but he didn't like
the idea that what you guys are going to blow up all of the ads
on this streaming channel cuz you don't like Hassan. Yep. Um
so, but maybe maybe this is consistent, right? If Ethan is only
going after these three people, maybe that seems uh more focused
to him. Well, I think what you were say, it's funny that you
say that because yeah, it's um he was he was pretty against the
like the gay ops of like mailing advertisers and trying to get
the whole platform in trouble. And now this would be the same
thing, right? This would be the same kind of thing where it would
be, you know, it might set a react precedent that Yeah. Yeah.
This could have a chilling effect, but this isn't like, oh, YouTube
is going to be or YouTube's going to be hurt or something like
that because this individual streamer got sued. I don't think
it works that way. Uh, Gabe Prelay, you're literally not listening.
You are too stupid to understand what's going on on stream. It's
fine. Uh, I literally was just saying, "No, no, no. I don't think
like Doro is that bad." Are you talking to other chatters or
Yeah. Who? Yeah. What do you mean? I'm I don't know. I don't
know who he's talking about or what he's talking about there.
I think this is all YouTubers versus streamers because YouTube
value copyright more. YouTubers value copyright more. Um, sure,
but there's also like persistent copyright infringements on YouTube.
The issue all of the YouTubers had and what they've said consistently,
what Turkey Tom and all these people said before was, "If you're
reacting on stream, I don't care. Just don't post the video to
YouTube. Don't post it on YouTube and compete with me for YouTube
views right at the same time." That was very consistent across
every YouTube creator that I saw discussing this two years ago
was, I don't care if you live stream it on Twitch. I don't give
a Okay, go ahead and stream it. I don't care. But don't post
YouTube videos of it. Don't make a Don't create that market replacement
where I'm working. Now, let me let me um ask you to walk through
this. So, the way that Dan tried to go about it was let me at
Twitch, let me Dan Clansancy, let me Jeff Bezos, let me now go
and email the advertisers cuz something needs to be done to
[__] Uh, but what Ethan is doing, even though he
is targeting Twitch streams, right? This was Twitch streamers
that were reacting to this stuff. He's not going to Twitch. He's
not going to Dan Clancy. He's just going straight after the streamer
and not going through DMCA either. Yeah. Yeah. He's not going
through DMCA. Yep. So, does that mean that no one else is going
to give a No one else feels threatened by this? No one else feels
hurt by this? No one's platform feels like they're going to be
What is the actual chilling? Well, the legal precedent would
be the chilling effect, right? The legal precedent that isn't
even what is accurate about it. It's just you register that your
with the Library of Congress and then you can go after anybody.
That's already that's not a precedent. That's just But that's
not a precedent. He's not setting precedent. He just found he
found a way to hit people. Well, no, but this could set precedent,
right? It's going to be a case that is about fair use. It could
set precedent, but it could only set precedent in the opposite
direction, right? If they if the girls win, then the precedent
is that if you register even with the Library of Congress that
they can't get you, you would argue that there's no precedent
needs to be set here, does it? If this is already how the Library
of Congress works. Um, so it doesn't necessarily have to be set,
but they'll still determine like actual damages and stuff. It'll
still be run as a copyright case. As far as I know, it'll still
be run as a regular copyright case. it will still be evaluating
like fair use and all of this. It's just that there will be statutory
damages attached to uh like him winning if he does. I'm just
I'm just making sure that we're saying the same thing like cuz
when you say set a precedent that means that like this is the
first time it's ever been done and nobody but I don't think we've
had a fair use case that's gone like the distance in terms of
like going all the way to the Supreme Court uh for 10 years or
15 years or something like it's been a long time. There's been
really almost no precedent set here.
Hold on. Okay. Wait. I feel like we're I'm just getting caught
up on the use of
If this this is what it's this is what this is designed for.
If you from what I understand, he's just registered his content
in a way that he can protect it. That's what that is for. And
so he has the right
to do this. It like no precedent needs to be set. That's the
whole purpose of registering
his content. So what is the precedent that you're talking no
precedent needs to be set here. This is by design.
possibly my understanding would be that this is this adds this
is basically still going to be a fair use claim. Now it doesn't
necessarily set precedent but there have not been very many YouTube
things specifically with react content that have been litigated
and so it will set a precedent in the react like content on YouTube
like this kind of media. It will be setting a precedent there.
Now, will it set precedents that are like I don't know what precedents
will be set. I just I think I think the word precedent means
something in this
Okay. Like it might start a trend I think is what you want to
say. Sure. But if it's So I' again I'd have to look at the the
venue for this. It's a US District Court. So it will be in a
federal court. So it will be setting a federal precedent somewhere.
Other cases that are trying to litigate this for like YouTube
copyright, right, will likely cite this case.
Will it get like dragged up to like the Supreme Court? Not necessarily,
but it will be a it will be like a court case that is that is
like ruled on and will be a precedent for this kind of YouTube
react content.
I think you're like just married to the word precedent. Um so
I think I think if you register your content in this way by design
it's so that you can
you know uh get whatever recoup your your losses. But I guess
but you mean this will be the first time that people see it utilized
by YouTubers because I think you said previously it was mostly
used by like the music industry record labels
very much like most of these things don't get litigated.
Okay. So by setting a precedent, you just mean that YouTubers
will understand that they can use this to protect
what their content. It depends on where the case goes. Like we
actually don't know what the So because copyright and specifically
the four pillars of like fair use are so difficult to understand
and like they're so nebulous. Basically, people operate in like
this clouded world where like it's possible that no React content
is legal. It just never gets ruled on, right? And there's no
reason to think that a judge will look at this and go, "Okay,
I'm ruling in Ethan's favor." And I see and then when they give
their reasoning, they what they say could possibly be used by
other people to say, "Oh, well, the judge didn't say that like
it wasn't it was uh it would be fair use if not for malicious
intent." It's like, "No, no, no. The idea that they were streaming
it at all, rereaming it at all was actually all rereaming is
bad." Right? The fact that they were rereaming this at the same
time, actually, that's all disallowed now or something. like
there I don't know how the judge will justify the ruling but
I believe that gets put into the like that will be become like
you know a court case that's decided and other court cases will
try to build off of this or it could get like brought up into
higher courts as well like getting uh what you call like appeal
you're saying it's going to set a precedent just for the fact
that it's being used um with with the YouTube content with video
formatted content. Yeah. Well, yeah, specifically. Yeah. Okay.
Um, and so because it's not going the other route,
um, the chilling effect is the fact that it like what it could
mean for other content creators, how they will protect their
content and in what ways like react content creators might have
to consider
how they behave and how they react to content, but nobody's worried
about their platform and stuff like that. So, do you feel like
less people are going to be invested in the actual outcome? Y
everyone's just going to look and be like, "Oh, well, I'm not
going to be as stupid as Denims and say that." Exactly. There'll
be a lot of really dumb people like Leiline Lost who think that
this argument right here that um that a judge will take into
account at all the fact that they said in terms of saying what
is legal, what is allowed and not allowed, that the judge will
take into account these people being malicious. You're taking
that for granted and you are stupid, right? You have no idea
if a judge will take that into account or not, if they care or
not. And so a precedent could be set here that has nothing to
do with that at all. and you're totally supporting it because
you hate Caseyron. Good luck. Because like you said earlier that
the the malice that has to do with recouping the the damages,
but you don't have to I think you can sue to get stuff taken
down without um what was the word that you used?
Statutory damages. Is that what you said? Yeah, statutory damages.
Yep. So, you need malice to recoup statutory damages. Um, but
can you successfully get something taken down without proving
malice or getting those damages?
Um, could you get it taken down? Sure. Through DMCA or something.
Yeah, you could. You could. You could. Yeah. Without seeking
those damages, you could do that. Yes.
Yeah, you could still you would run basically the same case.
I'm assuming that this would normally follow a DMC and you can
like the the utilization for being able to take people's videos
down without even caring if you get money for it or anything
like that. That's like silencing critics,
right? We still do it like that. Yeah. No one wants to put in
the work of No one wants to put in the work of criticizing someone's
content um really thoroughly and making like really good cases
against it and then it still gets taken down. Yeah, exactly.
We we wouldn't want that. And but I think a lot of people are
looking at this case and they're going, "Oh, obviously that won't
happen." And I don't believe that is obvious because like honestly
the whole the whole idea of these cases operate in in a gray
area that like that we actually don't know. We have no idea that
they'll just go oh well you can't do like this one thing. They
could very well say actually you're incorporating somebody's
copyright like at all in this in your YouTube video in a way
where like you don't have their permission actually that's like
I think that shouldn't be allowed right like like
they could say things about fair use here that maybe get undone
by other courts or something but it's like you just don't know
and I think it's a weird it might be weird I don't know I I don't
like litigation around this at all. I would like for him to basically
ask for the stuff to be taken down. I hate the idea that it was
that it was set up beforehand that they were like, "We're going
to sue these people no matter what." Because I don't think I
think if none of these people did this, if none of these people
said this explicitly, I believe they'd still be getting sued.
I believe it was a deliberate plan to sue these people regardless
of what malicious intent they showed on the stream. Do you remember
the start of Kick deciding, "Okay, we need to be a bit more serious.
You guys stop doing movie streams, stop like specifically stealing
content." Um, it just it started getting they started scrutinizing
all of that. And I remember we were watching
uh IRL streamers, what was their name? Wild Latina and her boyfriend.
Do you remember who that is? Uh, Duncle. Yeah. Yeah. Dunle. We
were watching them two argue and it felt like something serious
must have happened cuz the stream got taken down and we were
like, "Oh my god, what happened to them? What happened to them?"
And it wasn't even that anything violent happened. There was
Spongebob playing in the background and Kick just wasn't around.
Yep. Yeah, they just had something banned the guy because Spongebob
playing in the background. Like that's how shook people are about
I don't know copyright or at least that's how strenuous um like
Nickelodeon like other platforms are with their video copyright.
Yeah, exactly. Uh I think like basically nobody wants to risk
the lawsuits right now. Like it could actually upend the entire
industry. That's why I think these streaming websites are so
like careful about it. Also, just the
Oh, go ahead. The other Oh, it might be. The other argument I'm
seeing in chat is people are saying EAB and like RLM are good
examples of fair use. Have they won? Have they won legal cases?
I'm sorry, but Wild Latina and her boyfriend arguing and fighting
with Spongebob like barely playing in the background. That feels
like transformative. I didn't even know Spongebob was on at that
moment. Oh, sure. Yeah.
For sure. Yeah.
Um, yeah. With regards to like fair use, it's just all unknown.
It is all like a total black box. We have no we have no visibility
into what it's going to actually mean. No idea. Because think
about it. I don't think the courts are like, "Oh, no, no, no,
no. You were combating misinformation or you were um you did
something that that entirely changed it." the person who makes
the content. Spongebob just gets to decide, hey, I don't want
Spanish people yelling in front of my TV show. It's bad for my
image. It like it doesn't matter if it doesn't change your product
whatsoever. They just get to decide that this uh affects the
art that they created. Yeah. Well, and the other thing about
DMCA is that it favors like the content owner so much, right?
like the the DMCA stuff. It's just like, oh, you get taken down
before. You you immediately get taken down and then you get to
decide if the person who's like quoteunquote rebroadcasting or
reusing that content if you are going to risk a lawsuit. So like
you you get taken down and then you can you can appeal and say,
"Oh, well, if they if they really think so, they'll they can
sue me. Here's my identity, right?" That's like the process of
going through DMCA, which is also like not great because because
that's like going to be the big thing that you're going to look
at this from, right? Because like Loki is saying, Ethan's argument
is blah blah blah. These people are good. Nobody cares about
what Ethan's argument is at um in this moment. Obviously, we
do overall for his case, but uh after his case, what can anyone
else argue to have like the same outcome? Wait, so say that again?
As in like the next person, like maybe you think Ethan has like
valid reason for going after it, but you don't know if this precedent
that Ethan sets means that the next person can't utilize it for
like really egregious reasons themselves, right? Yeah, it might.
Well, and I think that basically what they'll do is it'll just
become case law, right? And then other cases that go down the
same path, the judge will say what he's thinking when he goes
to rule in the case, right? And that will be used by other people.
They'll cite it. It will be used to strengthen other arguments
and we don't know how that will go. Like this could be the first
domino in a bunch of dominoes that like really up like basically
the whole thing that's going on with streaming right now. And
people say well actually if it just gets rid of people maliciously
stealing entire videos then I'm fine with that. You have no evidence
that that will happen. You have no knowledge that that'll happen
right? You don't know that that's where it will stop. Okay. Now
do me a favor. Let's say I don't want to think too hard right
now. What is the correct opinion that I should have? What is
the correct? I hate people suing over this stuff when I don't
think that this is when they're not trying to like make a moral
stand. If they wanted to go after the people really creating
market replacements, really doing harm, I would support that.
You want to say this is actually a wrong, I would support that.
Okay. But they're not really going after the people replacement.
I think I think XQC is like the primary one. If I was going to
go after one person, probably be XQC. Okay. That's why Ethan
brings him up in the beginning of the video, but that's not what
he's doing here, right? And do we have ways to qualify why XQC
is a market replacement? Is it like the the cult streamer following
that these people literally cannot function watching a video
without XQC?
Another another one of his arguments would be that he actually
brings like more market more business to that person, right?
He helps them. That would be another argument he tried to make.
Um what were the other ones? The the lack of market replacement.
I think the streaming thing and again it's like the streaming
thing. Lots of these people consistently said, "I don't care
if people stream my stuff." Like, that's fine. Just don't create
a market replacement via YouTube. Don't create something that
is like uh crystallized that can be viewed later multiple times.
I think that's like a big Okay. Okay. That's what you mean by
Okay. Okay. Yeah. I think I think XQC puts all of his videos
on YouTube. Admin Gold has started doing that now. Admin Gold
has some though. That's the That's the problem. So we can say
market replacement is if let's say they
uh react during the like the live premiere or if they basically
upload the reaction to the entire uh content piece to the entire
content piece like immediately after with similar titles, similar
thumbnails, and that they like basically
kind of steal from the recommendations that the video would get
otherwise is the arguments people have made in the past because
I believe we watched some of Asmin Gold's reactions and I don't
think he ever uploads an a reaction to an entire piece that we've
like watched. I think as of recently he'll have like a 40minute
react, but he maybe looks at maybe 5 minutes of a video and then
he's just like yapping. Yeah. So he did he did this whole video
like he did the whole content nuke, but I think it's 3 hours
48 minutes. He probably actually is transforming the content.
It's with a lot of like it's probably with a lot of saying nothing.
Okay, you guys, you don't know that this is the way. This is
just how it is, guys. Isn't that just how it is? Yeah, it is,
isn't it? That's really just how it goes. That's the way she
goes. That's the way the cookie crumbles, guys. Here I am hitting
play again. Um, it might just be that. But, and I think for Ethan,
he doesn't feel like those are egregious, but that doesn't mean
that if Ethan is successful that someone like Asmin Gold couldn't
get hit in the future for something like that. Yeah, it doesn't
like he could be he could be hit in the future. Yeah. X is on
camera saying he knows and doesn't care about copyright. ex's
on camera basically saying um his his another argument he made
which is not a smart legal argument. Okay, was everybody's doing
it. Sue me if it's a problem. Everybody's doing it. Sue me if
it's a problem, right? I'm not going to let everybody else get
a bag off of doing this right now and not not dip in myself at
all and you sue me if it's a problem. And then he did the worm.
True. True. And then he did the worm. Wasn't even good. I I just
hate like uh I hate people getting legal with these things. I
don't like that it's going after streamers. Obviously, I'm a
streamer. I And if I had some idea or some understanding that
this would only be for people who basically upload with essentially
no commentary at all, right? Then I would then I would like agree.
I also don't know what Denim's commentary is. So, we'll have
to see if they if they talk about it in this lawsuit. We haven't
even started it yet. So, we we got to get reading. Her chair
is in here. her chair is in here. The nightmare on Denim Street.
It really seems to me that these things are being
like these are publicity stunts more than they are lawsuits,
but we'll see how it goes. Okay,
one introduction. Oh, wait. Should we read the quotes? Relying
on you to stay live so we don't have to give the nuke views.
Yeah, I'm going to stream it since I he confirmed it's coming
out today. I'm going to stream it. Denims prior to reacting to
content nuke Hassan.
Well guys, if you enjoyed not giving any views to that terrible
video, give me a follow, subscribe, throw a prime my way if you
like my content. If you like my content. What? Okay. Yeah. Uh,
the law one introduction. The lawsuit. Sorry. Did you want to
make a comment before we start? Uh, no. No, you're fine. Okay.
This lawsuit is about ending the practice of lazy reaction videos
that copy entire copyrighted works and purposely siphon views
and revenue away from the original. Over seven years ago, the
owners of plaintiff TED Entertainment Inc., TI Ethan and Hila
Klene established the legal standard for fair use reaction videos
in H uh Husten Zeday versus Klein 276. So some precedent here
as a genre reaction videos vary widely in terms of purpose, structure,
and extent to which they rely on potentially copyrighted material.
Reaction videos like the client video that intersperse short
segments of another another's work with criticism and commentary
constitute fair use. In contrast, reaction videos that are more
akin to a group viewing session do not. Um, and this is from
their own thing. So, more akin to a group viewing session.
Again, quite
quite oh, how would we put this? Oh, man. There's also there's
a huge thing since this this is only talking about YouTube videos,
right? And this is now talking the other one is talking about
live streams. I think there's quite a big difference and that
I don't know if you would argue Ethan Klein's thing is actually
solid precedent. probably if you were a legal if you were a lawyer
arguing against this, you might say that Ethan Klein's lawsuit
isn't precedent because it's not YouTube video to YouTube video.
They're different uh different mediums, right? No, I think you're
going to argue because of the premier thing. I'm saying I'm going
to argue something different.
Okay. Because I think probably with regards to the premiere,
I would say that is a market replacement. You're interfering.
But I would say just this video or sorry, this lawsuit might
not be solid precedent because it's live stream versus actual
video. Yeah. Because I will say the premiere is a live stream
and it is uh YouTube is a lot better with live stream now than
it was uh before. So you actually do hurt him in the algorithm
by taking views away from his live premiere. Yes. Yep. He doesn't
get to go as viral when there are like tens of thousands of people
intentionally watching off of his channel. Yeah, I agree. I was
I was more trying to make a like a point on his uh his previous
case rather than like the actual merits of this case. This this
case involves a group viewing session hosted by defendant. Uh
this is apparently I don't know if Denim's name is out there.
Denim's specifically intended to intended her group viewing session
to siphon views and revenues away from Tedd uh TEI's copyrighted
works. One content nucle
show 105 countdown to doomsday. Uh oh only these two. I thought
it was going to be all three. Denims tied her group viewing sessions
to coincide with this exact the exact moment TEI released the
works. Her timing was intended to capitalize on the intense public
interest in the works and siphon the maximum amount of views
of revenue or and revenue away from the works to herself by showing
the works in their entirety or nearly in their entirety. The
moderators of the H3 Stark subreddit, the H3 Stark mods, heavily
promoted Denim's group viewing sessions as an alternative to
the original works on the H3 Stark subreddit. H3 Stark. As a
direct result, Denim's group viewing sessions of the works peaked
at approximately 45,800 concurrent viewers
uh when her previous stream only achieved approximately 3,300.
Denims greatly profited from her group viewing session of the
works of the works uh or sorry from her group viewing session
of the works through advertising revenue, donations, and paid
subscriptions. Like most lazy reaction videos, Denims peppers
her group viewing session of TEI's works with primarily brief
and sporadic observations which can be categorized as follows.
A most frequently denims will watch long, unadulterated portions
of the works and briefly pause to give short surface level and
often repetitive observations that provide little to no new information,
new aesthetics, new insights or understandings on the original
works. And this is um have a chilling effect, but this isn't
like, oh, YouTube is going to be or YouTube's going to be hurt
or something like that because this individual streamer got sued.
I don't think it works that way. Uh gay for free delay, you're
literally not listening. You are too stupid to understand what's
going on on stream. It's fine. I literally was just saying, "No,
no, no. I don't think like Doro is that bad. Are you talking
to other chatters or Yeah. Who are you right now? Yeah. What
do you I don't know. I don't know who he's talking about or what
he's talking about there. I think this is all YouTubers versus
streamers because YouTube value copyright more. YouTubers value
copyright more. Sure, but there's also like persistent copyright
infringements on YouTube. The issue all of the YouTubers had
and what they've said consistently, what Turkey Tom and all these
people said before was, "If you're reacting on stream, I don't
care. Just don't post the video to YouTube. Don't post it on
YouTube and compete with me for YouTube views right at the same
time." That was very consistent across every YouTube creator
that I saw discussing this two years ago was, I don't care if
you live stream it on Twitch. I don't give a Okay, go ahead and
stream it. I don't care. But don't post YouTube videos of it.
Don't make a Don't create that market replacement where I'm working.
Now, let me let me um ask you to walk through this. So, the way
that Dan tried to go about it was, "Let me at Twitch, let me
at Dan Clansancy, let me at Jeff Bezos, let me now go and email
the advertisers cuz something needs to be done to
uh but what Ethan is doing, even though he is targeting Twitch
streams, right? This was Twitch streamers that were reacting
to this stuff. He's not going to Twitch. He's not going to Dan
Clancy. He's just going straight after the streamer and not going
through DMCA either. Yeah. Yeah. He's not going through DMCI.
Yep. So, does that mean that no one else is going to give a No
one else feels threatened by this? No one else feels hurt by
this? No one's platform feels like they're going to be like what
is the actual chilling well the legal precedent would be the
chilling effect, right? The legal precedent that isn't even what
is accurate about it. It's just you register that your with the
Library of Congress and then you can go after anybody. That's
already that's not a precedent malicious violation. That's just
but that's not a precedent. He's not setting precedent. He just
found he found a way to hit people. Well, no, but this could
set precedent, right? It's going to be a case that is about fair
use. It could set precedent, but it could only set precedent
in the opposite direction, right? If they if the girls win, then
the precedent is that if you register even with the Library of
Congress that they can't get you. You would argue that there's
no precedent needs to be set here, does it? If this is already
how the Library of Congress works. Um, so it doesn't necessarily
have to be set, but they'll still determine like actual damages
and stuff. It'll still be run as a copyright case. As far as
I know, it'll still be run as a regular copyright case. It will
still be evaluating like fair use and all of this. It's just
that there will be statutory damages attached to uh like him
winning if he does. I'm just I'm just making sure that we're
saying the same thing like because when you say set a precedent
that means that like this is the first time it's ever been done
and nobody but I don't think we've had a fair use case that's
gone like the distance in terms of like going all the way to
the Supreme Court uh for 10 years or 15 years or something like
it's been a long time. There's been really almost no precedent
set here.
Hold on. Okay. Wait. I feel like we're I'm just getting caught
up on the use of precedent. If this this is what it's this is
what this is designed for. If you from what I understand, he's
just registered his content in a way that he can protect it.
That's what that is for. And so he has the right to do this.
Like no precedent needs to be set. That's the whole purpose of
registering his content. So what is the precedent that you're
talking? No precedent needs to be set here. This is by design.
possibly. My understanding would be that this is this adds this
is basically still going to be a fair use claim. Now it doesn't
necessarily set precedent but there have not been very many YouTube
things specifically with react content that have been litigated
and so it will set a precedent in the react like content on YouTube
like this kind of media it will be setting a precedent there.
Now will it set precedents that are like I don't know what precedents
will be set. I just I think the word precedent means something
in this
Okay. Like it might start a trend I think is what you want to
say.
Sure. But if it's So I again I'd have to look at the the venue
for this. It's a US District Court. So we'll be in a federal
court. So we'll be setting a federal precedent somewhere. Other
cases that are trying to litigate this for like YouTube copyright,
right, will likely cite this case.
Will it get like dragged up to like the Supreme Court? Not necessarily,
but it will be a it will be like a court case that is that is
like ruled on and will be a precedent for this kind of YouTube
react content. I think you're like just married to the word precedent.
Um so I think I think if you register your content in this way
by design it's so that you can
you know uh
get whatever recoup your your losses. But I guess but you mean
this will be the first time that people see it utilized by YouTubers
because I think you said previously it was mostly used by like
the music industry record labels
very much like most of these things don't get litigated. Okay.
So by setting a precedent, you just mean that YouTubers will
understand that they can use this to protect what their content.
It depends on where the case goes. Like we actually don't know
what the So because copyright and specifically the four pillars
of like fair use are so difficult to understand and like they're
so nebulous. Basically people operate in like this clouded world
where like it's possible that no React content is legal. It just
never gets ruled on, right? And there's no reason to think that
a judge will look at this and go, "Okay, I'm ruling in Ethan's
favor." And I see and then when they give their reasoning, they
what they say could possibly be used by other people to say,
"Oh, well, the judge didn't say that like it wasn't it was uh
it would be fair use if not for malicious intent." It's like,
"No, no, no. The idea that they were streaming it at all, rereaming
it at all was actually all rereaming is bad." Right? the fact
that they were rereaming this at the same time actually that's
all disallowed now or something like there I don't know how the
judge will justify their ruling but I believe that gets put into
the like that will be become like you know a court case that's
decided and other court cases will try to build off of this or
it could get like brought up into higher courts as well like
getting uh what you call like appeal you're saying it's going
to set a precedent just for the fact that it's being used um
with with the YouTube content with video formatted content yeah
well Yeah, specifically. Yeah. Okay. Um,
and so because it's not going the other route, um, the chilling
effect is the fact that it like what it could mean for other
content creators, how they will protect their content and in
what ways like react content creators might have to consider
how they behave and how they react to content, but nobody's worried
about their platform and stuff like that. So, do you feel like
less people are going to be invested in the actual outcome? Y
everyone's just going to look and be like, "Oh, well, I'm not
going to be as stupid as Denims and say that." Exactly. There
will be a lot of really dumb people like Leiline Lost who think
that this argument right here that um that a judge will take
into account at all the fact that they said in terms of saying
what is legal, what is allowed and not allowed, that the judge
will take into account these people being malicious, you're taking
that for granted and you are stupid, right? You have no idea
if a judge will take that into account or not, if they care or
not. And so a precedent could be set here that has nothing to
do with that at all. and you're totally supporting it because
you hate Caseyron. Good luck because like you said earlier that
the the malice that has to do with recouping the the damages,
but you don't have to I think you can sue to get stuff taken
down without um what was the word that you used?
Statutory damages. Is that what you said? Yeah, statutory damages.
Yep. So, you need malice to recoup statutory damages. Um, but
can you successfully get something taken down without proving
malice or getting those damages? Um, could you get it taken down?
Sure. Through DMCA or something. Yeah, you could. You could.
You could. Yeah. Without seeking those damages, you could do
that. Yes. Yeah, you could still you would run basically the
same case. I'm assuming that this would normally follow a DMC
and you can like the the utilization for being able to take people's
videos down without even caring if you get money for it or anything
like that. That's like silencing critics,
right? We still like that. Yeah. No one wants to put in the work
of No one wants to put in the work of criticizing someone's content
um really thoroughly and making like really good cases against
it and then it still gets taken down. Yeah, exactly. We we wouldn't
want that. And but I think a lot of people are looking at this
case and they're going, "Oh, obviously that won't happen." And
I don't believe that is obvious because like honestly the whole
the whole idea of these cases operate in in a gray area that
like that we actually don't know. But you have no idea that they'll
just go, "Oh, well, you can't do like this one thing." They could
very well say, "Actually, you're incorporating somebody's copyright
like at all in this in your YouTube video in a way where like
you don't have their permission." Actually, that's like I think
that shouldn't be allowed, right? Like like they Yeah, they could
say things about fair use here that maybe get undone by other
courts or something, but it's like you just don't know. And I
think it's a weird it might be weird. I don't know. I I don't
like litigation around this at all. I would like for him to basically
ask for the stuff to be taken down. I hate the idea that it was
that it was set up beforehand that they were like, "We're going
to sue these people no matter what." Because I don't think I
think if none of these people did this, if none of these people
said this explicitly, I believe they'd still be getting sued.
I believe it was a deliberate plan to sue these people regardless
of what malicious intent they showed on the stream. Do you remember
at the start of Kick deciding, "Okay, we need to be a bit more
serious. You guys stop doing movie streams. stopped like specifically
stealing content. Um, it just it started getting they started
scrutinizing all of that. And I remember we were watching
uh IRL streamers, what was their name? Wild Latina and her boyfriend.
Do you remember who that is? Dunle. Yeah. Yeah. Dunle. We were
watching them two argue and it felt like something serious must
have happened cuz the stream got taken down and we were like,
"Oh my god, what happened to them? What happened to them?" And
it wasn't even that anything violent happened. There was Spongebob
playing in the background and Kick just wasn't around. Yep. Yeah.
They said something banned the guy because Spongebob
playing in the background. Like that's how shook people are about
I don't know copyright or at least that's how strenuous um like
Nickelodeon like other platforms are with their video copyright.
Um yeah, exactly. Uh I think like basically nobody wants to risk
the lawsuits right now. Like it could actually upend the entire
industry. That's why I think these streaming websites are so
like careful about it. Also, just the other argument I'm seeing
in chat informative. Oh, go ahead. The other Oh, it might be.
The other argument I'm seeing in chat is people are saying EAP
and like RLM are good examples of fair use. Have they won? Have
they won legal cases?
I'm sorry, but Wild Latina and her boyfriend arguing and fighting
with Spongebob like barely playing in the background. That feels
like transformative. I didn't even know Spongebob was on at that
moment. Oh, sure. Yeah. They're not winning each other for sure.
Yeah.
Um Yeah. With regards to like fair use, it's just all unknown.
It is all like a total black box. We have no We have no visibility
into what it's going to actually mean. No idea. Because think
about it. I don't think the courts are like, "Oh, no, no, no,
no. you were combating misinformation or you were um you did
something that that entirely changed it. The person who makes
the content, Spongebob, just gets to decide, hey, I don't want
Spanish people yelling in front of my TV show. It's bad for my
image. It like it doesn't matter if it doesn't change your product
whatsoever. They just get to decide that this uh affects the
art that they created. Yeah. Well, and the other thing about
DMCA is that it favors like the content owner so much, right?
like the the DMCA stuff. It's just like, oh, you get taken down
beforehand. You you immediately get taken down and then you get
to decide as the person who's like quoteunquote rebroadcasting
or reusing that content if you are going to risk a lawsuit. So
like you you get taken down and then you can you can appeal and
say, "Oh, well, if they if they really think so, they'll they
can sue me. Here's my identity, right?" That's like the process
of going through DMCA, which is also like not great because because
that's like going to be the big thing that you're going to look
at this from, right? Because like Loki is saying, Ethan's argument
is blah blah blah. These people are agreed. Nobody cares about
what Ethan's argument is at um in this moment. Obviously, we
do overall for his case, but uh after his case, what can anyone
else argue to have like the same outcome? Wait, so say that again?
As in like the next person, like maybe you think Ethan has like
valid reason for going after it, but you don't know if this precedent
that Ethan sets means that the next person can't
utilize it for like really egregious reasons themselves, right?
Yeah, it might. Well, and I think that basically what they'll
do is it'll just become case law, right? And then other cases
that go down the same path, the judge will say what he's thinking
when he goes to rule in the case, right? And that will be used
by other people. They'll cite it. It will be used to strengthen
other arguments and we don't know how that will go. Like this
could be the first domino in a bunch of dominoes that like really
up like basically the whole thing that's going on with streaming
right now. And people say well actually if it just gets rid of
people maliciously stealing entire videos then I'm fine with
that. You have no evidence that that will happen. You have no
knowledge that that'll happen right? You don't know that that's
where it will stop. Okay. Now do me a favor. Let's say I don't
want to think too hard right now. What is the correct opinion
that I should have? What is the correct? I hate people suing
over this stuff when I don't think that this is when they're
not trying to like make a moral stand. If they wanted to go after
the people really creating market replacements, really doing
harm, I would support that. You want to say this is actually
a wrong, I would support that. Okay. But they're not really going
after
I think I think XQC is like the primary one. If I was going to
go after one person, probably be XQC. Okay. That's why Ethan
brings him up in the beginning of the video, but that's not what
he's doing here, right? And do we have ways to qualify why XQC
is a market replacement? Is it like the the cult streamer following
that people literally cannot function watching a video without
XQC?
Another another one of his arguments would be that he actually
brings like more market more business to that person, right?
He helps them. That would be another argument he tried to make.
Um what were the other ones? The the lack of market replacement.
I think the streaming thing and again it's like the streaming
thing. Lots of these people have consistently said, "I don't
care if people stream my stuff." Like, that's fine. Just don't
create a market replacement via YouTube. Don't create something
that is like uh crystallized that can be viewed later multiple
times. I think that's like a big That's what you mean by Okay.
Okay. Yeah. I think I think XQC puts all of his videos on YouTube.
Asmin Gold has started doing that now. Asmin Gold has some though.
That's the That's the problem. So we can say market replacement
is if let's say they
uh react during the like the live premiere
or if they basically upload the reaction to the entire uh content
piece to the entire content piece like immediately after with
similar titles, similar thumbnails and that they like basically
kind of steal from the recommendations that the video would get
otherwise is the arguments people have made in the past because
I believe we watched some of Asmin Gold's reactions and I don't
think he ever uploads an a reaction to an entire piece that we've
like watched. I think as of recently he'll have like a 40minute
react, but he maybe looks at maybe 5 minutes of a video and then
he's just like yapping. Yeah. So he did he did this whole video
like he did the whole content nuke, but I think it's 3 hours
48 minutes. He probably actually is transforming the content.
It's with a lot of like it's probably with a lot of saying nothing.
Okay, you guys, you don't know that this is the way. This is
just how it is, guys. Isn't that just how it is? Yeah, it is,
isn't it? That's really just how it goes. That's the way she
goes. That's the way the cookie crumbles, guys. Hit up here.
Here I am hitting play again. Um, it might just be that. But
and I and I think for Ethan, he doesn't feel like those are egregious.
But that doesn't mean that if Ethan is successful that someone
like Asmin Gold couldn't get hit in the future for something
like that. Yeah. It doesn't like he could be he could be hit
in the future. Yeah. X is on camera saying he knows and doesn't
care about copyright. X is on camera basically saying um his
his another argument he made which is not a smart legal argument.
Okay. Was everybody's doing it. Sue me if it's a problem. Everybody's
doing it. Sue me if it's a problem. Right. I'm not going to let
everybody else get a bag off of doing this right now and not
not dip in myself at all and you sue me if it's a problem. And
then he did the worm. True. True. And then he did the worm. Wasn't
even good. I I just hate like uh I hate people getting legal
with these things. I don't like that it's going after streamers.
Obviously, I'm a streamer. I I if I had some idea or some understanding
that this would only be for people who basically upload with
essentially no commentary at all, right? Then I would then I
would like agree. I also don't know what Denim's commentary is.
So, we'll have to see if they if they talk about it in this lawsuit.
We haven't even started it yet. So, we we got to get reading.
Chair is in here. Her chair is in here. The nightmare on Denim
Street. It really seems to me that these things are being We'll
see. I feel like these are publicity stunts more than they are
lawsuits, but we'll see how it goes. Okay.
One introduction. Oh, wait. Should we read the quotes? We're
relying on you to stay live so we don't have to give the nuke
views. Yeah, I'm going to stream it since I He says he's confirmed
it's coming out today. I'm going to stream it. Denims prior to
reacting to content nuke Hassan.
Well guys, if you enjoyed not giving any views to that terrible
video, give me a follow, subscribe, throw a prime my way if you
like my content. If you like my content. What? Okay. Yeah. Uh,
the law one introduction. The lawsuit. Sorry. Did you want to
make a comment before we start? Uh, no. No, you're fine. Okay.
This lawsuit is about ending the practice of lazy reaction videos
that copied entire copyrighted works and purposely siphon views
and revenue away from the original. Over seven years ago, the
owners of plaintiff TED Entertainment Inc., TI Ethan and Hila
Klene established the legal standard for fair use reaction videos
in H uh Husten Zeday versus Klein 276. So some precedent here
as a genre reaction videos vary widely in terms of purpose, structure,
and extent to which they rely on potentially copyrighted material.
Reaction videos like the climb video that intersperse short segments
of another's
work with criticism and commentary constitute fair use. In contrast,
reaction videos that are more akin to a group viewing session
do not um and this is from their own thing. So more akin to a
group viewing session.
Again, quite
quite oh, how would we put this? Oh man, there's also there's
a huge thing since this this is only talking about YouTube videos,
right? And this is now talk the other one is talking about live
streams. I think there's quite a big difference and that I don't
know if you would argue Ethan Klein's thing is actually solid
precedent. probably if you were a legal if you were a lawyer
arguing against this you might say that Ethan Klein's lawsuit
isn't precedent because it's not YouTube video to YouTube video
they're different uh different mediums right
no I think so you're going to argue because of the premier thing
I'm saying I'm going to argue something different
okay because I think probably with regards to the premiere I
would say that is a market replacement you're interfering but
I would say just this video or sorry this lawsuit might not be
solid precedent because it's live stream versus actual video.
Yeah, because I will say the premiere is a live stream and it
is uh YouTube is a lot better with live stream now than it was
uh before. So, you actually do hurt him in the algorithm by taking
views away from his live premiere. Yes. Yep. He doesn't get to
go as viral when there are like tens of thousands of people
intentionally watching off of his channel. Yeah, I agree. I was
I was more trying to make a like a point on his uh his previous
case rather than like the actual merits of this case. This this
case involves a group viewing session hosted by defendant. Uh
this is apparently I don't know if Denim's name is out there.
Denims specifically intended to intended her group viewing session
to siphon views and revenues away from Teddy uh TEI's copyrighted
works. One content new Cass the nuke. Two, the H3 so show 105
countdown to doomsday. Oh, only these two. I thought it was going
to be all three. Denims tied her group viewing sessions to coincide
with this exact the exact moment TEI released the works. Her
timing was intended to capitalize on the intense public interest
in the works and siphon the maximum amount of views of revenue
or and revenue away from the works to herself by showing the
works in their entirety or nearly in their entirety. The moderators
of the H3 Stark subreddit, the H3 Stark mods, heavily promoted
Denim's group viewing sessions as an alternative to the original
works on the H3 Stark subreddit. H3 Stark. As a direct result,
Denim's group viewing sessions of the works peaked at approximately
45,800 concurrent viewers
uh when her previous stream only achieved approximately 3,300.
Denims greatly profited from her group viewing session of the
works of the works uh or sorry
from her group viewing session of the works through advertising
revenue, donations, and paid subscriptions. Like most lazy reaction
videos, Denims peppers her group viewing session of TEI's works
with primarily brief and sporadic observations which can be categorized
as follows. A most frequently denims will watch long unadulterated
portions of the works and briefly pause to give short surface
level and often repetitive observations that provide little to
no new information, new aesthetics, new insights or understandings
on the original works. And this is um this is another precedent
from copyright law they're reinforcing. Now, to me, that sounds
like they just don't respect her opinion. I would have to go
and watch some of these and see how closely this lines up with
somebody like XQC who would obviously be doing significantly
more damage. Right? That's going to be my argument. Hey, there's
somebody who is doing significantly more harm to this person
who who materially has no is no different under fair use who
they're not targeting. They are targeting me for a different
reason, right?
That would be that would be a big part of this. The most egregious
of her like I guess react content is when she just plays videos
before she even gets on stream. It's like a foolproof look at
her just ripping like Fox News or her ripping ripping whatever
um YouTuber. Sure. That would be malicious intent. Malicious
intent is not a part of fair use. It's not. Um what aboutism
doesn't work in court? I would say that I would say it. Oh man.
To me
It might not work and maybe he can just go after this person.
It does look weird when when there's like no other mention,
right? No other mention. It's not like he It's Sorry. It to me
it looks strange when he has explicitly called out another person
with regards to this kind of commentary who reacted to his video
who I'm guessing provided no better commentary than Denims herself
did, right? Who he's clearly had a problem with and then they're
not named in this. Well, I don't think that that
I feel like you get the social judgment for that. I don't think
you can make a legal claim.
Sure.
This person, you're you're right. You're right. You're right.
You're right. You're right. That is under the law. That's almost
certainly true. I'm more thinking yes of the social the social
argument. But I think your reputation takes a hit.
Okay. All right. Other times, Denim's commentary has little to
no critical bearing on the style or substance of the works. but
rather she goes off on tangents regarding unrelated subjects
or shadow boxes demonstrabably false misrepresentations of the
contents of the works.
Okay, again this is incredibly subjective. I don't know I would
want an example here. On the rare occasions when Denims does
provide sporadic and brief commentary on the style or substance
of the works, she spreads misinformation that is refuted moments
uh refuted moments later by the works themselves or by the most
cursory level of research. On the rarer occasions where she actually
shows the factual basis for her claim, she her statements are
refuted by the cited source itself. Such misinformation fails
to serve copyright's goal of enriching public knowledge. To the
contrary, such misinformation disdinishes it. Okay. Uh so it
doesn't it doesn't seem like all of these are basically Okay,
I'm seeing I'm seeing what they're arguing. They're arguing that
the it's a group viewing session, but when they do comment, it's
bad.
I wonder how much there is like I wonder how much commentary
is there. I just I we might have to go through and watch the
denim stuff to know for sure. Yeah. I mean there probably is
a difference right there probably is something valid where like
what did they quote enrich public what was it goal of enriching
public knowledge. So the the point of fair use is that you're
able to you know show things in news broadcasts. I think news
broadcasts are the best example. show clips of things in news
broadcasts where you um Oh, where you basically take a clip from
like something that happened that might not be your copyrighted
work and it's to make sure the public is informed. There's a
public interest in showing that along with the story, right?
Yes. Yeah. So, I I believe that's normally what uh what I I think
that's what a lot of fair use is about. Finally, Denims will
even do an empty chair reaction as shown above where she goes
off camera for an extended period of time while letting the video
play to keep her audience entertained.
The poverty of Denim's commentary coupled with her highly commercial
use of the works that she specifically intended to serve as a
substitute for the originals fails to justify copyrighting TEI's
works in their entirety or nearly in their entirety. Rather,
Denim's group viewing session is a quintessential example of
copyright infringement, i.e. the unauthorized exploitation of
TEI's works to get attention and avoid the drudgery in working
up something fresh. There's another one uh another citation.
So, basically, if you're if you're not original in any way, that's
a problem, right? which is clearly the case here that it's not
original. Uh or at least it's you know it is it is in fact like
derivative. It's a derivative work that the argument will be
how transformative it is. This lawsuit is to hold Denims accountable
for her infringement and the H3 Snark mods accountable for materially
contributing to her infringement. Oh, okay.
Um hold on. Let me uh let me duplicate this and pull it off screen
because I do want to see the
and dos 1 to 10. Okay. So, the doese's are listed with uh with
each of these, it looks like. So, hey, Stark Mods, party to the
cases.
We'll uh we'll see how it goes. That's good to see though. All
right. Jurisdiction and venue. Don't care. Parties. So, TEI denims
H3 Stark mods. And then it goes on to list all of the people
who are H3 Stark mods or a couple of the people who are H3 Stark
mods. Okay. Back to allegations. TI was founded in 2016 by Ethan
and Nila Klein. The Kleins rose to prominence on YouTube with
two channels, H3H3 Productions and Ethan and Nila, their secondary
channel. The Kleins created highly stylized reaction videos to
other YouTube videos. The client's reaction videos interspersed
relatively short segments of the original video with long segments
of the client's commentary.
After TEI was established, the clients both uh assigned both
channels to TEI.
In 2016, the clients were sued for copyright infringement, defamation,
and misrepresentation under 17USC section 512F by Matt Hashinsay.
Uh, also known as Matt Hos/thebold
Guy. The copyright claim concerned a reaction video uploaded
to their Ethan and Elich YouTube channel. The video entitled,
"So, this is going to be their original
Uh, that's fine that this is all about their original case. I
just I don't know how much of this we need to see. Let's see.
I'm looking over at chat as well. Okay. In 27 oh sorry on August
23rd 2017 the court granted summary judgement for the clients
on all of Matt Hos's claims for the copyrighted for the copyright
infringement claim the court found Ethan Klein vid Ethan Klein's
video made fair use of the hos video in 2017 TI established the
H3 podcast channel on YouTube on the new channel TI produced
podcast episodes that were less structured than the reaction
videos the clients previously made to ensure any use of unlicensed
copyright content qualified as fair use. TI formulated and refined
best practices based on the principles from their original case
which included whenever feasible pres pre-screening the original
work and outlining the criticism and commentary before the broadcast.
Two, ensuring the comment oh so they pre-watch everything.
Ensuring the commentary was directly related to the style and/or
substance of the original work. Three, only broadcasting the
portion of the original work that would be subject to critique.
Four, pausing the original work frequently to provide critique.
And five, ensuring that the duration and commentary uh duration
of commentary was substantially longer than the portion of the
original work shown portion of the original work show immediately
before the commentary shown. Okay, so these are their best practices.
Is this so based on principles from the original lawsuit? Which
principles are they based on? Is it just the idea that it should
be short interpers segments? Pretty hard to demonstrate you're
using copyrighted works in good faith without pre-watching. Maybe.
Uh I think there's some argument to that. I don't know if it's
always correct. Well, you could say that because you know who
Hassan is and you've watched their fallout and you've been covering
the drama back and forth between them that you are
that you felt that you were equipped to live fact check. Yeah,
exactly. I think I think you could I think there is like an argument
for this that live factchecking live reaction can be good and
you can do things. Yeah, I think um as long as you're creating
I'm not saying that she did a good job, but somebody probably
could have like explicitly going out of your way to create a
market replacement like like putting up barriers to that idea.
There's probably like absolutely an absolute requirement to to
try to follow fair use as much as you can. He watched the Content
Cop live as soon as it came out in its entirety, right? I don't
know. Like I I mean it's it's fine to me I either way, but I
think you I think you'd do it. I understand that these these
do help though. The pre-screening stuff. Anyway, Denims, the
alt left's answer to Kellyan Conway. Denim's okay. A lot of a
lot of this in here. It's very it's good stuff. Okay. Denim's
LARs live action roleplay. As a revolutionary from the comfort
of her bedroom in California, she's a prolific purveyor of misinformation
and speaks with great confidence on topics where her knowledge
leaves much to be desired. Dennis repeatedly inserts herself
into public controversies by employing poor judgment, knee-jerk
contrarianism, and a consistent impulse to defend the indefensible,
including copyright infringement, terrorism, and extremism, and
calling CPS. Denims is one of the most loyal and ardent defenders
of Hassan aka Hassanabi. Hassan the most pro Hassan is bad. The
most prominent alt left streamer on Twitch, much like Scientologists,
engage in Did they define altle left, by the way? What does alt
left mean here? Jeez. the most prominent alt-left streamer on
Twitch. Much like Scientologists engage in fair game, Denims
ruthlessly attacks with reckless abandon anyone who disagrees
with her or Hassan. She parrots Hassan's style, rhetoric, and
content strategy, i.e. regularly streaming React content with
minimal transformation or commentary.
As such, she has assumed a leading role in Hassan's waiting room.
Uh in Hassan's waiting room, a collective of streamers who cultishly
follow Hassan and parasitically leech off of his audience by
streaming before and after him. On November 17th, 2023, in a
now deleted video, Denims read Osama bin Laden's letter to America
in its entirety on stream. She frequently expressed agreement
and support for the letter, such as, "Hold on. Are we are we
arguing she violated Osama bin Laden's copyright? Is that is
this proof that she violated Osama bin Laden's copyright? Is
that what we're saying
Probably to her character or something like that." Um, I guess
so. I do want to say because I think some people are trying to
guess like what alt left means. I think it's generally
expected that in filings like this that you explain terms that
are not like colloquial colloquial right sure that sorry that
is the word colloquial colloquial yeah but um you're saying it's
hard to describe with words that are colloquial alt left here
to me alt left would just mean um like basically any progressive
leftist who's who like hates liberals who hates liberalism but
shouldn't they shouldn't they explain that in here like when
we read the desire Perez one, they literally outlined what it
meant to go through emotional abuse. They defined everything
from gaslight to physical violence. Uh yeah, they did not they
did not. I I think if you don't define alt left, which they haven't,
I I think this is mostly like um most of this lawsuit seems to
be a PR stunt, right? Like I believe also Ethan has been found.
So is there not another case where Ethan Ethan was found like
that he was engaging in like slap lawsuits? Am I crazy? I thought
there was a lawsuit like this. I'm trying to think of what the
guy's name was. I thought Ethan basically got one of his lawsuits
thrown back at him because it was deemed frivolous. I think so,
but I need to actually go and look it up. So, so she supported
and agreed with the letter. She frequently expressed agreement
in support for the letter such as America deserved 911. I can't
disavow facts, man. I can't disavow reality. That's not how that
works, bro. Then I'm reading from the letter. Why do they attack
us in New York and Washington? If Ariel Chiron is a man of peace
in the eyes of George Bush, then we are also men of peace. America
does not understand the language of manners of principle. The
language of manners and principles. So we are addressing it using
the language it understands. Denim's response, he's not wrong
about that. The US only understands violence. I'm okay.
All right. Yes. Against
YouTuber Ethan Klein loses anti-slap appeal in producer Ryan
Kavanaaugh defamation case. Okay. So this guy's suing him for
defamation and he said it was a slap lawsuit. So it was not quite
what I said, but this is what happened. Yeah. he lost his motion
to dismiss this um defamation case brought against him. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. So, I thought I thought it was that he was found
to be engaging in like a frivolous lawsuit, but it's not. It's
he tried to say a lawsuit against him was frivolous. A slap lawsuit,
which I forget what SLAP stands for exactly, but it's essentially
frivolous litigation, but won the overall case. Wait, he won
the overall case. Are you sure he did? It was Kavanaaugh thing.
He lost his anti-SLAP appeal, but won the overall case. Okay.
Strategic litigation against public participation. Okay. which
is what I feel like this is. But again, I he may he probably
has the law on his side here. So I we'll see how it ends up going.
I think I think the Library of Congress thing is probably going
to work here. Bin Laden's Bin Laden, not Bin Laden criticism
of the United States are all correct. Despite Twitch's prohibition
on terrorist propaganda, Twitch gave Denims a slap on the wrist
by banning her for just a day. Uh okay. On December 12th, 2022,
in a now deleted video, Dennis responded to the December 8th,
2022 video of June Nicole Lein, aka Shuan Head, which critiqued
Balenciaga's advertising campaign that depicted minors in a highly
BDSM attire. Rather than acknowledge the widespread concern,
Denims took the absurdly grotesque position of defending Balenciaga's
advertising campaign and attempted to put paint shoe on head
as homophobic despite shoe head not mentioning whatsoever. Okay.
All right. I is this just going to be like the the anti-denim's
greatest hits? Is that what this is? Good times. Okay. Denim's
involvement in the public controversy known as ReactGate provides
great insight into her willful disregard for copyright. In early
2022, Hassan and Denims along with several other Twitch streamers
received intense criticism for conducting group viewing sessions
of third-party copyrighted content without permission. In these
group viewing sessions, streamers like Hassan and Denims would
watch entire copyrighted works with little to no commentary,
sometimes even letting the video play when they were not present
or while the streamer was sleeping. The controversy reached a
fever pitch when the group when these group viewing sessions
involved mainstream television shows and films. So, this is all
of the Hell's Kitchen stuff, right? Hell's Kitchen, all of that.
Okay. Yeah, people are just mocking kind of this whole thing
where we're going through all of the things she's done wrong.
Anyway, on February 1st, 2022, the online creator online content
creator known as JXC released a video called Hass Jinx in the
issue of reaction content. In the video, JXE drew a distinction
between reaction videos that provide substantive critique and/or
additional insights into the original work and lazy reaction
videos that resemble group viewing sessions. In particular, JXE
focused on Hassan's group viewing sessions, including one, his
poverty of commentary, two, his penchant for doing an empty chair
reaction where he lets the video play while he is completely
off-creen, and three, his failure to credit the author of the
original video or link to the original content. Um, so this happened,
and this is what I'm talking about where I think I think there
are two very, very different criticisms going on here. And Ethan
has, I believe, possibly opened himself up. Can't believe lawyers
actually agree to put all this irrelevant in a complaint. So
for their
um, it's interesting. I think Ethan wants Well, I Yeah, I have
no idea. I these people literally get paid hoping that somebody
is so desperate to take somebody to court and pay for all of
this pointless work. Yeah. Yeah. Got to eat. I think the reason
he's mentioning all of these things is he wants to like drag
away from what he's actually suing over, right? I think and he
I I also think he wants to use his previous criticisms of React
content to kind of cover up the fact that I think I think he
kind of dared these people to do this kind of reaction, right?
Maybe not the live reaction, but I think there's a lot there's
a lot of stuff that we'll we'll be able to go through a lot of
transcripts of this stuff, right? That Chatter is mocking Destiny's
argument, you knuckle draggers. I don't think he's necessarily
doing that. Vigilant stream, I don't think I don't think he's
necessarily doing that. I understand the joke here that oh this
is all irrelevant. We shouldn't include it, right? I understand
the joke that it's like Destiny. I don't think Vigilant Stream's
doing that, but maybe he is. Okay. Uh where was I going? I just
lost a train of thought. Um oh, I think Ethan dared multiple
people and he said things like, and correct me if I'm wrong here.
I believe we have quotes that are along the lines of these people
are too scared to watch the video in front of their audiences.
They will never ever play that video in front of their audiences.
They are way too scared to do that. That will never happen. Right.
I I wonder and I understand he said Hassan a lot of the time,
but I don't believe did was there a way that he didn't slip up.
You guys think it was only Hassan? Wait, how why do we think
or why do we know that it's only Hassan? Why did he wait till
now to complain about anybody else doing it? Or did he complain
before? Cuz I I maybe he did and I just don't realize it.
Yeah. Well, I don't think he compl Well, he complained about
uh because here's my problem. Didn't he didn't he also, and this
is the annoying part, this is what people are going to say, like,
"Oh, nobody's stealing your content. You benefit off of them
reacting to it cuz then you can react to them." He did get to
react to Denim's reacting to it, right? And I'm not saying that
that means, oh, you absolutely have like no case here or whatever,
but to say that it didn't give you anything in return, I don't
know.
Um, yeah, sure. I think and I mean it sounds like he watched
Idubbbz's entire video like in real time as well like as that
released,
but I I just want to go and see if he if he called out like anybody
if he was ever not explicit about it being Hassan, right? If
he was ever explicit if he was ever not explicit and like leaving
it open and saying like these people, these leftists cuz he addressed
Denims and he addressed Froggen, he addressed a lot of these
people quite a few times.
Again, I'm like fine and I'm I'm fine that they have to do something
or say something or acknowledge that it's up to have taken the
live premiere reaction even if he is asking people to react to
it. I don't think he said that until after his live premiere,
right? Cuz he didn't what he didn't stream till afterwards or
the next day. Well, I don't know. Sure. like you're talking about
when he went uh like all of the times that he has ever said go
react to it or uh comment on it or debunk me that would have
all happened after the live premiere, right? I think Well, no.
I think I think he said before that. I literally think he was
invited before that. Okay, never mind. I don't know. I thought
maybe he didn't do any calls to like react or commentate on it
until after the video came up. I think No, I think he was pre-firing
them. I think he was like saying that Hassan was too much of
a [__] to watch it. Um I think but I my question
is is there really no and maybe people have checked the transcripts.
That would seem crazy to me if he never once said like you know
Hassan and all of his lackey or whatever none of them will watch
it. That kind of thing. I I think that would be very interesting.
But Zan would react to segments of the H3 nuke from his orbiters
reacting to it. Okay. Okay. Anyway, I'm I would just be interested
to know because I think to me personally,
this is a totally separate thing from his original. It's like
it's very very off-putting or sorry, it's very very um it's a
very big offshoot from the original arguments that were
Yeah, it's it's very big. I Oh, now I have to I feel like I have
to go back and watch the XQC versus Ethan argument. Like actually
go and see what the argument was. Yeah, that would be good. What
do you mean? I think his argument was about creating an ecosystem
with very large creators who would take from very small creators
and not pass on any of those profits. So they'd be making thousands,
hundreds of thousands of dollars, right? And they wouldn't be
passing that on. There'd be no tangible like benefit to the person
whose content they were looking at. I think that was the moral
wrong he was trying to correct. And I don't think this is the
same. I think this is quite different. And and I think probably
his original problem, the thing he had the original problem with
still exists, is still happening, has probably happened with
this video that he has this like copyright registered for, but
he won't he won't attack it. He won't go after those people.
In any case, okay, we we should probably continue. So, in a now
deleted response video, Denims defended the unauthorized use
of the copyrighted content by asserting that viewers prefer watching
streamers over original uploads, particularly when the material
is curated. She claimed that established fair use standards are
irrelevant to live streaming, including Twitch's content, and
not and need not be transformative through substantial commentary
or editing. Rather, Denim's claimed that a streamer's personality
alone can justify the unauthorized rebroadcast of copyrighted
material. Uh, I mean, I'm sure she argued that when she was stealing
entire episodes of Hell's Kitchen, right?
In any case, on February 6th, 2025,
Denims and JX conducted a debate about the proprietary uh propriety
of group. This can't be 2025.
Uh but the propriety of group viewing sessions that was moderated
by online content creator named Chudlogic. Let's go
the debate video. And during the debate, Denims makes several
damning statements about her personal perception on the unauthorized
use of copyrighted content. Some notable moments are listed below.
Early on in the debate, Denims acknowledges that she Sorry, one
second. Denims acknowledges that she I just lost my Denim acknowledges
that she uses third party content as filler and that it siphons
views away from the original. I just want to be clear on my opinion
on like filler content and stuff. Like I think filler content,
you shouldn't do it. I know I do it as a react streamer and I
try to I try to do it only with Vox videos or Vice videos and
stuff like that because I'm I'm not like directly ripping from
one content creator and not like a whole team and stuff. And
most of the videos have like 5 million views. I only get like
500 500 viewers likely. I'm not even going uh going to be taking
out I'm guessing may maybe 50 views from the video. It's a lot
harder to feel like I guess bad about that. So, she's saying
because of the small uh small effect I have, I don't really have
to worry about it. Unlucky.
Hold on. You're multi-millionaire. This is this is like this
is what I understood as. So, I just want to say first off, like
I was saying, thank you for um Whoops, bro. Nice try. You literally
do it to enrich yourself. you're a multi-millionaire and you
steal content from small creators and you don't give a about
their rights or what they want and then your only justification
is, oh yeah, you can come chase me down and complain and try
to get my attention so I can pay you for the I stole. It's total,
bro. You're not creating anything big for anyone. You're just
taking attention and views for yourself and you don't give a
about the the uh the consequences of that. It's not your decision
to make that for other people's property.
You sound like um watch out like Robin Hood or something. Are
you like some sort of hero or something like that? Cuz it seems
like you do a lot of that and you take high defense. You take
the high road on that one. That's that my point. You have
he's not stealing from anyone. Yeah, he's not stealing it from
anyone in this case. What? Uh yes, it is a moral argument. I'm
saying that that Ethan Klein through this content has tried to
take this moral argument which most people jive with and use
it to cover a a legal argument that is not really reinforcing
that moral argument. Right? He is not doing this thing. He is
not saying it's wrong that this happens. That's not explicitly
what he's doing because he's not trying to solve that problem.
Like that is not the issue he's trying to solve here. Right?
Like a huge part of why he talked about all of this, why everybody
was talking about all of this was because it was small content
creators over. And that's not that's not at all what this is
about. Now, who cares though? I care. I'm gonna keep pointing
it out. He's arguably he's arguably going for the smaller, easier
targets. So he basically I understand it's not like he doesn't
have a case. It's not like he isn't uh maybe valid to be upset,
right? Uh that's fine, but don't also wear like the crown like
I'm going after the problem that we've all been talking about
for years. You're going after your enemies.
Yeah, you're going after you're going after your enemies. The
three toads did it to themselves. Baby, I'm just I'm just laughing
at you guys who are like, "Oh, I'm laughing at anybody who watches
that video and thinks that the things he talked about with XQC,
the things he's been railing about for years are the problems
he's trying to solve now." He is not trying to solve those problems.
He doesn't care about those problems. He cares about punching
Caseyron in the face. That's what he wants to do, right? That
is what he cares about. I will say if after he and the concept
that small trying to if he's trying to have the foolproof way
of getting it done, it just has to be that don't celebrate him.
Don't reward him right now. Reward him when after he gets these
people that he feels confident enough to go after XQC. If he
feels like he's done his due like due diligence, whatever, he's
won the war after he gets three these three streamers. Like that's
ridiculous. Exactly. Yes. And well it's it's I mean he can do
it. I just I would worry that there's like downstream effects
like yeah basically when he so he tries to give himself the coverage
right which is what what Dan tried to do right exactly as Cherry
said earlier. He tries to give himself the coverage that like
oh obviously like substantial reactions like where you're pausing
and making commentary. I don't want to affect those at all. But
he doesn't know that. He doesn't know that he won't affect those.
It doesn't really concern him that he might affect those. It's
not a part of he doesn't care. Right. So, he's he's not going
after like XQC or some of the bigger people. He's kind of he's
just hitting the people he can and he's not really concerned.
If he was doing this, if he was risking this because he had a
moral problem and he's really trying to fix the system and he's
going after somebody who's a major violator, somebody who he
already attacked, that would make a difference to me. I understand
that you guys don't care, right? But I that's that's what I don't
like about this. Sorry, I want to go back to this time stamp
here. And the concept that small creators wouldn't want to start
with XQC, one of the biggest uh with the craziest fan base in
the world, like is that really a foreign idea to you that they
wouldn't want to deal with this power dynamic? Like you would
crush them if you said anything. Your fans would harass them
into oblivion? That's too foreign for you to to understand. So
So Oh, that's a really bad argument from Ethan Klein given the
current climate. Th this guy um 400k subscribers, big YouTube
videos, small creators that's about to die from something. Ethan
is here for to save the day. This person will now be able to
afford some food and eat some rice tonight. Well, I'm just saying
because if you make a portrait, if you draw a picture on who
this person is and you say small creator like struggling and
whatnot, I'm saving him and you're just
you are misrepresenting it. So he doesn't matter. Oh yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, he does matter. But not in the capac not in the capacity
that By the way, did this go too late? I thought there was a
start to this that was more substantial for this this whole point.
I don't know if this time stamp went through correctly. Your
channel is dead. If Ethan wins, stay pressed.
Uh, okay. I would just find other content to do, but okay. You're
trying to paint. Which is what? I don't understand. What? Hold
on. Which major streamer's channel is not dead if this happens?
Pot of Harrows. Oh, sorry. Okay. He's talking to Riyle. I can't
see it. I'm like maybe I don't know. I do a lot of full reactions
to videos. It's like it's like a part of what streaming is right
now. You just follow the metas, right? Civ streams are back.
Maybe. Anyway, we'll uh we'll argue with people after this. In
any case, I think this is enough for this one. We we can get
back to the actual docket here. I would consider your transforms
your reactions transformative. They are, but I don't know that.
Listen, I don't know that my videos will be transformative enough.
I don't know. Think you guys are misunder No, I'm not misunderstanding
his argument at all. I'm I'm understanding totally that he can
make this legal argument and the legal argument would be the
same in both cases. I'm following his moral argument and what
he says bothers him, but nobody else cares about that. It seems
like anyway, hold on. We can keep going here. So, so she says
it's all about the small how small she is. So, this is this might
actually come into being like important because she says here
are the reasons it's okay for me to do this as a react streamer,
right? And then clearly in the circumstances where she takes
Ethan's content, this none of this is true, right? If she has
50,000 live viewers watching this content, ripping it directly,
then none of this argument she said would like morally absolve
her applies.
This this one might actually be a little bit more relevant to
the legal case, right? Especially to go towards her state of
mind and what she's thinking. Start registering your streams
with the Library of Congress and get 150K every week. Maybe,
dude. Cuz I do think that losing um losing tens of thousands
of viewers for a live premiere does hurt you in the algorithm.
So, like where the could have been. Yep. Definitely could. Like,
I'm sorry. Definitely would. I Sorry. My defin You're 100% correct.
I was adding in that in my head. I don't know if any of those
viewers would watch that live. I think they would wait to watch
it with the streamer. In in any case, they could. So, it I think
they probably wouldn't have been able to the live premiere. they
would have still watched it through a streamer. If a streamer
wasn't stealing it for the live premiere, it would have been
helpful. But that helps make the point that there's something
that streamers do that
uh effectively
hurts the the work of a YouTuber, someone who's uploading a video,
streamers can have a direct impact on them, right? If you're
saying that here are all of these viewers who would never go
and watch this, but maybe if these streamers don't make a habit
of stealing like live premiered content that these viewers might
actually go watch it.
Maybe. But like it's just the fact that someone's always there
to make sure they never have to or something.
Sure. Yeah. Sure. I think I think broadly that's just true morally.
I don't know if that's I you'd have to show it somehow and I
don't know how you show it. I don't know if it's quite enough
to just say like obviously that happens. That's my that's would
be my concern in a legal case. I think it's I think it it's likely
it happens. These are all the same arguments as before. But you
can prove the opposite, right? If those viewers will show up
to the live stream and they'll stay there and they're retained
by the content, then that means that these are potential viewers
of that video.
Maybe that's a that's a better argument. I like that more. Yeah,
sure. That like obviously if uh if she stops watching the content
nuke and then 40,000 people disappear, there's also something
going on there where those people were only there for that content.
Yeah, sure. I mean, it's it's literally by design that he didn't
tell people when he would go live with this premiere. So why
is there such a huge influx into Denim's like live stream that
normally would not be there if it's not the fact that there is
a demand to view this video so much so that they will watch it
through her. Yep. They're not with her for any other reason.
So I would argue that could be the case for him.
Sure. Yeah, I think so. Like I I like that argument quite a bit
more. I'm still I would have to argue it. I have to like let
a lot of these things ruminate in my head. Don't take my lack
of response as like saying you're right or wrong. I'm like thinking
of how this jives with what I think. So, food for thought. Exactly.
Thank you. Feeding my brain because Hassan wasn't live and in
Japan. Oh, so you guys are asking why Hassan wasn't streaming
this. Okay. Later in the debate, Denim sets forth her theory
to justify a group viewing session of third party content. That
Twitch streamers are curators that provide a communal experience
of watching content with their audience who do not want to take
the time to find YouTube content on their own. Oh, is you're
actually right about what you missed. Dude, she's so she's just
not good at making any art. She's not good at like covering her
tracks. Or maybe she's just an awful person. I don't know. Uh,
you know, I'm sure if you click on a random part of the video,
I might not be saying anything. Sure, whatever. I might walk
away from the screen, but it's about like the communal thing.
It's not about the actual show at a certain point. So, I sorry,
I think that's actually misstating it to when I heard this. To
me, it's like it's about the community. It's about watching this
with a chat that like likes I think there is something to that
argument. By the way, I think we watch a lot of content on this
stream that other people wouldn't necessarily like or care about
and they'll watch it on this stream because of the community
that's here, because it's from the people that they like watching,
right? I think there is absolutely a point to that and that will
be a pretty consistent number that you'll see throughout, right?
Cuz that's the community.
Sure. Well, yeah. Sure. Sure. Sure. That that if you if you 100x
there's something else happening. She has to Yeah. She has to
literally abandon this idea. Oh, it's a communal thing when you
all of the sudden like 1,000 times your viewership, you don't
know who the they are, what community. Exactly. Sure. Like probably
for XQC when he watches when XQC watches the content nuke, he
probably doesn't really go up that much in viewers, right? But
there's something else going on with Denims when she watches
the content nuke and she 100xes in viewers.
Okay. I hope I didn't just cut out there. No, I didn't. Okay,
good. Okay.
Uh, so we got to this part. Uh, it's like, oh, it's the same
reason you watch shows with your friends. You want to watch it
with other people, right? I think when it comes to streamers
on Twitch, a lot of people go watch streamers on Twitch for their
react content almost as a curator. So, they don't actually want
to go through the YouTube themselves and watch a bunch of videos.
They probably never will go to YouTube and click on a bunch of
videos. This is like the worst argument of all. I've never seen
a worse argument than like, "No, they're just too lazy to go
click a YouTube video, so actually I do that." That's crazy.
Oh, thanks, Lord. Lord Divon, thank you. I don't give a about
half the you have on the screen. I watch because I appreciate
your honest opinion on the subject. Thank you. Love this guy.
Somebody VIP that guy. What an awesome comment. What an awesome
uplifting comment in the moment. We love Lord Duvian. I don't
know how often you hear Lord Dvon, but I appreciate that buddy.
Thank you. Ban him. Okay.
Do not ban him. Denims, however, ultimately concedes that when
a viewer watches content curated by a Twitch streamer, it serves
as a substitute for the original. There's no point of watching
something a second time. You already watched it. Maybe Oh, that's
where I would say you're totally wrong.
And if anything, when we watch like that Tommy C content, when
we do top 10, how does Tom 10 blows that concept out of the water?
Right now, I think that's more to do with like streaming content
versus streaming content, the reaction thing you can get going
on. I don't think that has as much to do with curated videos
like curated edited videos. You're probably not watching the
content nuke. Well, no. The content nuke I think is actually
a part of that too. I would say a lot of this content I in my
intuition is like a part of this thing, right? When you're engaging
in this back and forth with these streamers and on your podcast
and you're releasing a video to to like these people up in the
in the political landscape, right? That's what you're all doing.
I think I think that that intent changes things for me somehow.
And I don't know how that could be considered an illegal case.
Do you guys know what I'm saying? That like this was a part of
an argument with streamers that you knew they were responding
to, that you copyrighted explicitly so you could sue them after
they responded and you had been going back and forth with them
with your podcast and you sort of slipped in a a curated piece
in the middle and were like, "I dare you. I dare you. I double
dog dare you. Go for it. Try it. See what happens." I somehow
in my head that that feels like it's happening here. You're never
watching the original after you've seen the reaction that contains
the entire original. I don't know if that's 100% true. So, if
you see the entire original, possibly not. Uh, I've definitely
watched a lot of streamers where they are watching something
that I want to watch and I go, "Oh, I hate this person's commentary.
I'm going to go watch the actual video." Like for Caseyron,
I you can't make this argument for Casey Trunk because obviously
she said things that kind of put her in legal hot water, right?
But for Caseyron, if I turned Casey Tron's on and saw like the
Ethan Klein content nuke and wanted to see it, I'd watch her
cough three times and I go, "Fuck this. I'm going over to YouTube.
I'll find this video myself. Bye.
We have We have literally done the thing where we're like, "Oh,
okay. Just reacting to this video. Maybe he's got the link. Like,
I'm not trying to watch this person react to it. I want to see
the video." Yeah. So, I feel like if streamers will do that,
why wouldn't Chatters That's not just by the way, just throwing
it out there. That's not just Okay. That's ev every streamer
when I know that they're watching something like also when MRO
does it. I Okay, stop. Stop. Stop.
It's not
definitely when Stardust does it. Oh, you're not going to tell
me to stop now. I
Why? Why? We just have to We just have to keep fighting with
people. It's crazy. Somebody Well, somebody in chat asked, "Why
is Cherry Oscar the Grouch?" And you've answered asked and answered.
Okay, hold on. Denims. Yeah, we looked at Denim Solnome over.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We we looked at we literally went and looked
at her max viewers on that stream.
Although I don't know. I feel like she got a huge boost. Is that
just from Dude, is is there that big a hate watching? I feel
like what I would look for if I were Denims is I would say actually
let's go look at like the Hassan the Hassan Discord. Can we get
the Hassan Discord logs and see if there was like an at here
or something? Because I don't know if does is H3 Stark that big
that they could push 50,000 viewers on a damn stream? 40,000
viewers. story on Dem's stream. I actually don't know. I would
be looking for other places. Check Twitters. He wipes tweets
and stuff. Check tweets and what do you mean? Oh, check tweets
to see if Oh, if people were saying to go watch it with her.
Yeah, cuz I actually don't know where the boost from Denims came
from. And the idea that it came from Stark. I don't think that
could possibly be where all of that's coming from. I feel like
I feel like it was the H cord. I feel it was the Hazord or something
around Hassan or Hassan tweeted it out because to me
there's no way H3 Stark pushed that many viewers to Denims, right?
That can't possibly be the major precipitating factor in her
getting all of those viewers. I think it's got to be Hassan's
community cuz it's essentially Hassan's viewer base that's there.
Han Well, Hassan couldn't have watched at that point Digi Waffle
because Denims was uh Denims was live. Hassan was gone. Hassan
was on vacation. I believe there's also a bunch of botting on
that day. I remember seeing like 70k in Greek Godex's stream.
Oh, interesting. Anyway, okay. There's uh no point watching something
a second time. You already watched it. Maybe like if you're watching
it with some other people or something, it's been a long time.
You might rewatch the video. But once you watch the video in
one place, it's pretty unlikely you're going to go back and watch
it again. Debate video 30. So, sure. Someone watches content
on someone else's stream, there's a very low likelihood that
they're going to go watch it separately and give you the view
or the like. Debate video. Sure. I think that's probably true.
Background of H3 Stark. H3 Snark is part of a genre of message
boards known as subreddits on the website Reddit. Snark subreddits
consist of fallen fans of a particular entertainer. Over time,
there may have been numerous snark subreddits regarding TI's
podcast and of the clients. Many were banned from by Reddit for
violating its content policy such as r/nemies and r/nemies 2.
H3 Snark was created on August 30th, 2023 by D number one, who
was a fanatical Trisha Pis fan. Do number one became a fallen
fan when the TEI series Frenemies, which was co-hosted by Ethan
and Trisha, ended abruptly in June 2021. That is clearly true.
Yeah, I think it is clearly true that this is the case. Um, I
still don't know if that creates a like it's debatable the circumstances
under which it creates a market replacement, I
Um, like there's something else going on here, okay, that I want
that I want us all to understand and feel like uh it takes
Oh, I I'll have to like figure out I'll have to write stuff down
and try to elucidate it better. But there's something going on
here when where Ethan's involved in like a ton of back and forth
with Denims and Denim's audience and Hassan. There's like all
of these back and forths going on all at the same time. and then
Ethan releases a content piece and that that community of people
that Ethan's been criticizing for like a year and a half don't
want to watch his stuff and they want to go and do it through
their own community, right? I think there's something going on
there where like that's sort of understood like oh, how could
I don't know how to put it? There's there's something going on
there that I think you have to account for, but only in a only
in a moral sense, not really in a legal sense necessarily. You're
saying that he has almost unreasonable
um feigned ignorance as to why there is an audience that doesn't
want to support him. Say that again. Sorry, I was reading Hunter's
comment there. I need you to say that again one more time. He's
got like an unreasonable feigned ignorance to why there is an
audience built up that does not want to support him. They're
very vocal. Yes, guys, for absolutely no reason. streamers.
Tens or hundreds of thousands of people hate me for no reason.
Yeah.
He's blaming it on the streamers. Yeah. And so what he would
have to do is uh the same complaints that he asked about Hassan,
like Hassan, you're entirely audience captured. You're playing
into the terrorist propaganda because that's your audience. That's
who's going to pay for pay you blah blah blah blah blah. that
same influence. He has motivated an audience to
influence denims and all these other people in that way. He understands
audience capture. He understands his anti-fans. And then but
he pretends he doesn't, right? Pretends that like these people
could be neutral. These people could be neutral. Like they were
going to watch they could easily click his videos and watch his
videos, but Yeah. Evolved.
Yeah. But he he is able to point to denims like perfectly because
this is an example of somebody who is actually captured like
absolutely captured by like vanity, right? She's uplifted and
has no idea why and it's not because of any of her thoughts or
critical thinking skills and that's why she gets caught time
after time after time saying really stupid. Cherry means that
it's because of her community, the community and like groups
she belongs to, not because of what you guys thought or anything
adjacent to something Tech would say. Just to be clear. Okay,
just to be clear, those are not what that's not what Cherry's
saying. All right. No, Sophia, thank for the primer. A lot of
leftist ideology just doesn't um doesn't always make sense. Okay.
And if you are just performative being a leftist, you're not
going to always make sense. And I think it's easy to get caught
up when you are audience captured to be that type of leftist
if you don't if you're not really about that life. Well said.
Okay. H uh I need to Where were we with this? Oh, the paid
fans. Sorry you guys. Okay,
we're big Denims fans here for very different reasons. I just
love anybody who uh certain people off. Okay, that's what I mean.
Jerry likes denims for like actual reasons. I'm just like denims
makes people very mad and that that makes me laugh. Totally.
I think everyone gets their chance to be an on the internet and
make money off doing it. I don't like why do I have to make an
enemy of her or hate her if she gets under your skin? Sure. Yeah,
it's valid. actually why Kelly liked Hassan while we covered
that guy. Didn't like Hassan, sorry. Just didn't hate Hassan
in the way that I did. You know, Han is bad. Yeah. Okay. All
right. H3 Stark became a haven for fallen fans of Ti's podcast
and the clients. While the average viewer would move on with
their lives after becoming disinterested in a podcast, H3 Stark
fallen fans religiously watch Ti produce content with orastic
hatred or of or resembling an orgy? I can orgies be like uh can
you have hatred via an or I feel like that's weird.
I Okay, it's fine. I just didn't know what it meant. Uh so they
watch TI produced content with orastic hatred. I don't know.
Yeah, I don't think you can have a hate pile. I don't think that
works, bro. I don't think that's anyway.
Uh, they continue to make it H3 Stark enables these deranged
and chronically unemployed fallen fans to share their perverse
pleasure of hate watching TEI content with others by providing
infringing clips and links to content that Denim's spike in viewership
could have been botted. We know this was planned in advance and
bots are cheap.
Uh, entirely possible. I I don't know. So, I have no evidence
of that. I'm not going to make a positive claim. That's entirely
possible. I don't see a like a ton of evidence that. Excuse me.
So, we just have to see. Yeah, that's I feel like it's almost
certainly more Hassan's audience watching her, but hard to say.
Okay. Uh, beginning in the fall of 2023, H3 Stark experienced
a surge of new users who were fallen fans of the TI series Leftovers.
As mentioned, the show was co-hosted by Ethan Hassan, who is
the most prominent alle streamer on the website Twitch. On September
14th, 2023, Ethan and Hassan debated various issues concerning
China and Taiwan, such as the whether Taiwan should be independent,
the propriety of China's subjugation of Tibet, and the genocide
of the Ugers, Wagers, Weaggguers, I think. Due to Ethan's push
pushing back on Hassan's pro-China positions, several leftovers
fans who had ecclesiastic parasocial who had an ecclesiastic
parasocial relationship with Han flocked to the H3 to H3 Stark
because they felt Ethan was critiquing them personally. The surge
of new users to H3 Snark exploded after October 7th, 2023. The
clients are dual Israeli citizen dual Israeli American citizens.
Aa was born and raised in Israel where she served as a secretary
during her mandatory conscription into the Israeli Defense Forces.
While E while both Ethan and Ela are highly supportive of Palestinian
self-determination and extremely critical of Israel and its government,
the and the Klein's support of two two-state solution as the
best interim solution to the conflict. In the wake of October
7th, Hassan emerged as the modern incarnation of the grand MUI
Haj Amin al- Husseini. Al- Husseini. Like Al Husseini, Hassan
became a passionate advocate and highly charismatic leader of
the Palestinian cause.
This is the the guy who met with Hitler, right? Big big hat,
big beard, met with Hitler, shook Hitler's hand. Hitler here
being Idubbbz, obviously. Okay. Like Al Husseini, Hassan used
his massive platform to spread genocidal rhetoric about anyone
advocating for the right of self-determination in their ancestral
homeland, i.e. Zionists. The primary difference between Hassan
and Al Husini is that Al Husini worked with the Nazis and advocated
the annihilation of Jews.
While Hassan advocates the annihilation of all Zionists,
since the vast majority of Jews in the United States say caring
about Israel is essential or important, this would necessarily
include the vast majority of Jews, even if they support the Palestinian
cause and vehemently condemn the actions of the Israeli government.
So, I've just never seen Hassan say that any Zionist in America
should be right. So, Hassan advocates the annihilation of all
Zionists. Has he said all people who care about Israel here should
be killed? I've heard the dog walker comment and that's getting
pretty far over there. But I just don't think Hassan's quite
into, you know, genociding like 90% of America. I just don't
I don't think so. Or he's got a different version of Zionism.
Oh, look. It's the guy in the hat with Hitler. Incredibly important
legal arguments on the way, guys. This is the man I am calling
Hassan. Okay, Hassan is this guy. Here he is with Hinrich Hinrich
Himmler. Here he is with Adolf Hitler. And now imagine this is
Hassan. This is Hassan. I need you to understand that this is
Hassan. Okay? And you we we know this because Hassan is famously
shaking hands with Nick Fuentes and not only Nick Fuentes, but
also the guy who runs Stormfront. I can't remember the dude's
name, Andrew Angland. Okay, best friends, Nick Fuentes. Andrew
Angland. Obviously, these dudes are basically the same. Let's
go. Arabs, rise as one, rise as one man and fight for your sacred
rights. Kill the wherever you find them. This pleases God, history,
and religion. This saves your honor. God is with you. Al Husini,
March 1st, 1944 on Nazi radio. Can we Can we admit that Ethan
Klein's like lost his mind? Can we admit this? Can we admit this?
That publishing this like he has clearly lost his mind. This
is, by the way, I just want to point out this is a lawsuit against
Okay, this is a lawsuit against Denims. Okay. On October 12th,
2023, the last episode of Leftovers aired. It comprised of a
discussion between Hassan and Ethan and Hassan regarding the
Israel Palestine conflict and the events of October 7th. During
the discussion, Ethan expressed his support of the Palestinian
cause and empathy for their suffering along with condemning Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu. At the same time, Ethan attempted
to humanize the victims of October 7th to Hassan in the hope
that empathy and mutual understanding could begin to heal the
divide. Hassan was unpersuaded and the relationship with Ethan
and Hassan began to deteriorate. In the aftermath of the falling
out between Ethan and Hassan, H3 Stark became a radioactive hub
of fallen fans of TEI content and the Kleins. It became a focal
point for spreading vicious lies, outlandish conspiracy theories,
and hallucinatory misrepresentations about the Kleins. So once
again, I believe Ethan has
almost entirely misrepresented this. Okay, I don't believe that
the biggest spikes in anti-fan production would have been when
Ethan was c crying and saying, "Could you please have some empathy
for me?" I just don't believe it. If you believe it, I have a
bridge to sell you. Okay. I believe that it was mostly his responses
and people feeling that those responses were inappropriate. Door
catcher thing is a direct quote from Felix Bamman. It's not even
a Hassan original. Oh, I see. Well, that's interesting. In any
case, like I don't I believe most of the anti-fandom comes from
Ethan's responses, a lot of his response videos and stuff, right?
And now I think I have a ton of empathy for Ethan in those situations.
I'm not going to hate Ethan for being upset right after October
7th, but I understand how other people will. But pretending that
it was like when Ethan was crying and saying like, "Hey, uh,
I I really hate Benjamin Netanyahu." And everybody was like,
"Oh, you you you only hate Benjamin Netanyahu. You're not willing
to genocide all Zionists." Um, yeah, we're anti-fans now. I don't
think I don't think so. Okay. So, quoting his favorite Jew hater
is any less bad. Wait, Fuve, do you have any idea who Felix is?
What do you mean his favorite Jew hater? Is Felix not? Am I Am
I lost? Oh, he is. Okay, Felix. Felix is the guy who's like the
super disgusting like pthead, right? Who comes on and basically
slobbers into a microphone and slurs all of his words together.
That's Felix, right? Isn't that Felix? I thought Felix was the
guy who's like really really gross who like gets super high and
just slobbers and that's really funny. Felix.
Oh, hold on. Reuben Ruben donated $5,
here's five bucks to free the white names. White names rejoice.
Uh, I don't know if I can do that. Reban Ruben, I need to see
is this has this reached its critical mass here. Oh, it has.
Well, I did say admins could release when uh when we released
or when we hit the the number. But if they don't want to, I got
you. Oh, hold on. All saved. White names freed.
Discord can go hard.
Discord should go hard. Okay, you guys are back. I I did say
after we hit the numbers they could go, but we just hadn't hit
the numbers. So, jeez. Felix is a gross person who also supports
the of all Zionists.
Clip. Can I have a clip that all Zionists should die? And then
I need his definition of Zionist. Okay, you can't you can't say
somebody's like, "Oh, I think um if somebody said something along
the lines of I think all materialists should die." Okay, that's
not a good one. I'm trying to think of a good example. Okay,
hold on. There's like some nebulously defined thing and somebody
says anybody who is that thing should die and then you do the
most broad definition. You say you actually want all of these
people to die. No, it depends on what they think the definition
is. Obviously, the dog catcher idea came from Felix. That's what
I heard. Anyway, back to back to the docket. Let's keep reading.
In the aftermath of the falling out between Ethan and Hassan
Oh, right, right, right, right, right. Hallucinatory misrepresentations
about the clients. The rampant copyright infringement on H3 Snark.
Despite their hatred towards the clients, the users of H3 Stark
had an insatable appetite for TEI's content. The H3 Snark users,
however, did not want TEI to receive any views or advertising
revenue from their consumption of TEI's content. As a result,
H3 Snark has become a locust of copyright infringement of TEI
content, as detailed below. One method the H3 Snark mods employed
to consume TEI content was to share links of TI content on YouTube.
Why would you say why would you spell YouTube this way? Hello.
Is this Is this lawyer good? This lawyer has like some typing
mannerisms that are not quite gone. This guy frequent contributor
to certain online message boards. Okay. Almost said something
he didn't want to say. A website that provides unauthorized access
to you. Oh, wait. No, this is a real thing. YouTube.
Oh, no. Hold on. This is a real thing. Wait. I thought it was
a misspelling, but YouTube is a way to
fork MPS YouTube is a way to watch. Remember to use YouTube to
view her content. Now, don't give her real views. It is a way.
It is like a explicit way to do this. There's somebody I have
no idea what this is, but this is somebody saying use this this
whole thing. Okay. So, it's like a a pass through so that you're
not giving views to videos. Very interesting. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Cool. So, a website that provides unauthorized Sorry, I saw that.
I'm just like, bro, I've seen I've seen some people type this
word before. YouTube had particular appeal to H3 Stark mods and
H3 Stark users because a video watched on YouTube does not result
in a view or advertising revenue to the original video on YouTube.
H3 Stark mods conducted live chats during TEI's live broadcast.
During the live chats, the H3 Snark Mods would spam the chat
with YouTube links of the broadcast. Once the Why are these people
not in their own lawsuit? Very interesting. I If these people
were persistently doing this, I don't like this at all. Right.
And they're not streamers. They're just like doing this to me
somehow feels so much worse, right? This feels so much worse
to me. It makes me think that these people should be in their
own thing. But once uh it might maybe it's less bad, though.
Maybe it's less bad in that they're not actually profiting on
their own. They're just doing it entirely out of spite.
Could be. Uh Venomous Villain, thank you for the subscription.
Is that a primer? Is that a Is that a kick sub? Is that a It's
a kick sub. Resubed eight months. Thank you very much, Venomous
Villain. Guys, if you like the content, okay, we are running
a long stream tonight, okay? We'll have a very long stream tonight.
We're going all the way. All right, we're going all the way.
And I need your help to do it, okay? I need you to follow on
Twitch. Follow on kick kick.com/jastk.
Twitch.tv/jsdk
with an underscore. All right, make sure you're following the
Twitch channel. All right, we're we live stream on Twitch for
a decent amount of streams sometimes. trying to grow up the Twitch
channel, get a bigger viewer base over there, get a community
going over there, have people typing over there so it becomes
like a a better base that we can uh build out from. Okay, so
don't forget to follow the Twitch, follow on
with an underscore. Same as Twitch. All right, join the Discord.
And if you want to take your support one step further, help the
stream go longer, you can gift me a couple subs, you can donate
some money. Exclamation point, donate in the chat, okay? You'll
get the the TTS links, every dollar from TTS, every dollar from
subscriptions, all goes towards more time on the stream. We are
somewhere around, I don't know, five, six, seven subs away from
two more hours on the stream. Okay, hitting our first stretch
goal, which is two more hours on the stream. 60 bucks, $30 an
hour. It's such a bargain. Oh my god. So guys, go ahead and sub
on kick. Give some subs on kick. Sub on Twitch. Throw your Twitch
primers at me, okay? Every dollar counts. Every dollar makes
a difference. really appreciate all the support. Uh Matt NLT
over on Twitch gave 10 community subs. Let's go. Thank you very
much, Matt. Thank you very much. Really appreciate you, buddy.
Huggers. Big big big support over on Twitch from Matt NLT. You
love to see it. Thank you, Matt. Uh we are going to add the two
more hours to the stream. I think I think we we'll do that. We'll
do that right now. Okay. What do we got? 2 hours 4418.
Thank you very much, Matt. He loved to see the support. Okay,
and I think that's basically it. Oh, last but not least, patreon.com/jastalkk.
All right, patreon.comjastk.
There is a whole bunch of
there's a whole bunch of stuff we have going on here. And don't
forget, guys, there's a 50% off discount going on. Okay, if you
put in the Patreon discount code 660
when subbing to the Patreon, you get 50% off your membership.
We are doing our first oiler call tonight, I believe. I believe
that's going to be tonight. We'll see. I'm not 100% sure. I believe
it will be tonight, though. Okay. So,
Exclusive content at the olot tier. Uh guaranteed permissions
to post your images and typing in uh in Discord if you're a white
name. Okay. If sorry, if you're a $5 supporter and you get, I
think, voice No, no, no. You get soundboards. Soundboards in
the Discord. Voice channels. Boom. Geez. I haven't done an actual
Patreon call to action in quite a while. Anyway, there's the
uh there's the discount discount code, guys, if you do want to
sign up for a month. Okay, 50% off the first month. Patreon disco
discount code 66E6.
All right, that's everything. That's all of it. Back to the content.
Hassan talked about it. Oh, we got Hassan commentary.
Let's check out the Hassan commentary. Hassan, he has that the
Assan industrial comp. Han reacts to Ethan dropping the lawsuits,
tells his audience to show support for Denims, Frogen, and Casey
Trron. He's going to use the ton of money that he has to try
to bully other content creators who don't have a ton of money
and try to win some kind of public opinion battle. That's basically
what I think is happening here. Uh I don't I don't think this
is a legitimate ch uh like want to change the system, need to
change the system. I think that whole thing is like some moral
dressing around him just being spiteful. Can he be spiteful cuz
these people are idiots? Yes. Is that good? I don't know. I don't
think so. But you hate these people so complex. I want the Ethan
industrial complex. I think it's a good idea. I like it. son
laugh to back that is just fantastic. Um yeah, I think it's really
cool and it's actually crazy how like many people are are seemingly
making a decent living. Yeah, I mean this is a desperate attempt
to grab on to [__] any sort of controversy and drama.
I'm sure that me reacting to it is actually playing into exactly
what he wanted to do. But the reason why I wanted to talk about
this is specifically so that you guys go and show support to
Denim's
Rogan and Casey Tron because obviously he has a ton of money
and he's going to use the ton of money that he has to bully other
content creators who don't have a ton of money uh and and try
to win some Son makes eight figures and might have a nine figure.
Why would he have a nine figure net worth? He doesn't have any
stocks or anything. He doesn't he doesn't believe in it kind
of public opinion battle. That is partially the reason why he
went after Froggen Denims and Caseyron. These are people who
get insane
lines of
So I think I do believe it's a public opinion battle. A lot of
people are saying that like oh Hassan should just fund their
lawsuits. I don't think Hassan funds all lawsuits that are like
done uh basically against like his friends. I don't I don't know
if that's like appropriate. It feels kind of weird that like
there's that expectation. Oh, Hassan's rich. Hassan should fund
it. Hassan's rich. Hassan should fund it. Hassan's rich. Hassan
should fund it. I I get the feeling that if I were Hassan and
everybody says this all the time, I'm feeling like my wallet's
like shrinking up. What about his mods? I have no idea about
his mods. I don't know what the argument is there. Yeah, they
they need to shut up. Hassan is rich and guess what? He lives
with his mom. Okay. He's a good boy. He's spending his money
very well and he's taking care of his family. You could never
Razle Smasher, you literally don't know any everything you just
said. You have no idea if that's true or not. You understand
that, right? Sorry, he's making a comment about the case. Like
literally, it's just the cognitive imprint that is telling you
that that's the case. You just said something you have no evidence
for. Or if you have evidence for it, go ahead and show me it.
But anyway, sorry. I I had to just throw that out there.
I don't know why I said he's a good boy. I It like came so natural
to me. I don't know why. But yeah, I I just don't think that
you are like some selfish dude if you are this well off and you
like literally take care of your mom and like she lives with
you. Like stop pocket watching. J, can we get a Cherry calls
you a good boy redeem thing? No, that will be probably a $25
donation tier. Okay, maybe you get it at a $25 donation tier.
Do you do you live with your mom?
some people have suggested this.
Uh, hold on. You just linked you just linked a uh motion. Okay,
I will read this later. I don't have time to read it now. Um,
if you want to if you want to highlight and go to the Discord
Rousle Smasher and show me in the what is it called? The defense
squad room. You want to go there and lay out your argument? I
can view it after the stream, but it's not a part of the content
right now. I'll check it out in a little bit. So, apparently
Frogan just wiped her whole Twitch channel, deleted all of her
Twitch VODs, or at the very least unlisted them. Um, yeah, that
makes sense to like unlist.
I think probably doesn't Twitch only give you 30 days of retention
anyway? Probably her VODs would be gone from before. Uh, also,
has she been banned recently? I do know that this can happen
sometimes when you get banned and unbanned. As gold reaction
to the same video, right into a camera and saying outright, "Hey,
I'm
now she up real bad." Oh, should we watch a little bit of the
little bit of Asmin Gold stuff here? I'm going to go through
the whole thing, Ry, just so you know. His reaction starts at
1 minute. Oh, wait. He doesn't talk until 1 minute in. Okay,
we could we'll start around here. We'll check this out. Community
interfere. Actually, the opposite. I hope that we can all unite
against this type of egregious behavior to destroy the commentary
community as we know it. Well, guys, uh if you enjoyed um not
giving any views to that terrible video, follow Why would you
do this? Why would you do this? If we watch the asmin gold react,
you will rewatch the same portion from the original, right? I
already watched the original. What? We literally just watched
it. You're trying You're trying to like win an argument and saying
something in the process. Why don't you just think through the
argument you're making instead of saying something stupid? That
was a Kelly Jean comment right there, evil Johnny Bravo. Not
cool, buddy. Not cool. What the hell did Kelly videos all He
didn't think through the thing he said cuz he just was he was
obsessed. He wanted a W on the Oh, you won't go back and watch
the original content thing. What does that have to do with Kelly
Jean?
Uh, absolutely nothing. I would never accuse her of doing that.
That's crazy. You are fighting ghost.
Okay. How are you messing this up for me? God damn it. Everything
was going great. Hello. Subscribe. Okay. That's funny though.
That's super f That's very funny to me. Okay. Okay. Wait. Replay
that. Replay that. Oh, you missed it. Bro, I react to videos
all the time. Why are you messing this up for me? God damn it.
Everything was going great. Subscribe. Throw a prime. That's
funny. These creators feel comfortable looking right into a camera
and saying outright, "Hey, I'm stealing this guy's content. Pay
me instead of him. This is not a healthy environment." Why would
you do Why would you do this? Why would they do this? Why would
you do this? Like whenever you're you're not even there and the
video is playing, that's not a react, bro. Like you could say
react area is a gray area. You're doing it on purpose. Yes. Stay.
So, here's the thing I do when I go to the bathroom. I try not
to be gone more than a minute and if I am like I'm listening
to my headphones and if I if I can't remember the things I'm
going to say in response to what I just listened to, I'll actually
just rewind and go back to it, right? Like I'll I'll rewind.
I think you can you can get up and grab stuff and not be at your
computer and be listening. I that's my personal opinion. But
if you don't comment on the stuff, like I feel almost compelled
to comment on the things I just heard as I'd gone to the bathroom
most of the time. I also, by the way, I don't even have I don't
even have an a camera on, so I could just not say anything. I
try not to, though. Or I try I try to be honest about it.
It's fair to say if you retain viewers while things playing while
off screen, they aren't watching you. Yeah, but I'm never on
screen.
Transforming by rewinding a bunch. Exactly. Yes. Malicious intent.
dated what I can't say what I mean how often do um what the chatter
said how often do you see a whole bunch or did you see we'll
say it was an old meta a whole bunch of people sitting in a Twitch
chat with the the letters saying outfit change be right back
nothing on the screen right but they are sitting there patiently
waiting
they're all patiently waiting for the day Denims actually goes
to the bathroom and she left like a lapel mic on. Okay, that
anticipation is keeping them all there at all times. All right.
Yeah, I remember. It's nothing to do with the content that's
on stream. Sorry, I took that too far. That was a good You do
that clip is doctorred. That is not an original clip. No. Yeah.
Yeah, that that's not an original clip. That's He literally paused
the stream. He stopped everything and told me
he's going to be late. Nope. Nope. Nope. But he made the whole
stream so quiet. None of that happened. I don't know why you
feel the need to come on stream and just lie about that. It's
very weird.
I just checked and Denim's reacted four hours to the 1 hour and
40minute content nuke. Isn't that pretty good? It is actually.
Yes. I would say that's almost certainly reaching towards being
transformative though. GG.
She has stated. How long was the chair empty for in the 4 hours?
Because maybe it's egregious of him to even just point out the
one time that she had to stand up and go to the bathroom real
quick over 4 hours. Yeah, I think it would be interesting to
go through and watch that stream. I wonder if people did go and
watch it. I'll never do it. I don't think I'm going to spend
4 hours watching a video I didn't want to watch in the first
place through Denim's POV. I actually would rather take a hammer
to my sensitive places on my body. Okay, my knees is what I was
going to say. All right, my knees then do that. That would be
awful. You guys, we can watch it in the Oiler call.
Okay, maybe. You never know. Possibly. Z Money says he watched
it. I somehow don't believe you, but maybe. Possibly. Malicious
intent. All right. Uh, let me I'm going to back it up a little
bit here so I can continue to freeload off of Asmin Gold. Okay.
Like whenever you're you're not even there and the video is playing.
That's not a react, bro. Like you could say react area is a gray
area. You're doing it on purpose. Yes. Stated malicious intent.
Stated malicious intent. If you enjoyed um not giving any views
to that terrible video, subscribe. Throw a prime. Denim's already
started the GoFundMe. So, she has raised $500.
Well, she could have done the bare minimum and skated through
easily. Yes. I think also, and this is a component that E. So,
here's the thing.
It looks like Denims, despite the malicious intent,
did actually stay live for
4 hours watching the content nuke, right? She Here's where it
picks up. And there appear to be 4 hours of stream for an hour
and 50minute video. I I some I somehow have a hard time believing
that that was non-transformative. To see the VOD that looks like
a argue that's just a graph. So, I think once we see the VOD
and it lines up with it being a 4-hour react, probably um make
this argument a lot better. She was watching the stream before
though, right? And we saw her reacting to the countdown. We did,
but I'm saying like, oh, wait, but how long was she reacting
to the countdown for? For like 30 minutes. Only relevant is her
transformative commentary. Except it said that there was commentary.
It just said it was like uninformed and bad. Uninformed and bad
commentary can be transformative. I would assume she has a 1
hour intro. She does. Go ahead. It's just it's the chairp point
again. If she really just got up and walked away for like seven
minutes to go to the bathroom and come back and he's going to
harp on that, it makes him look like malicious. Well, not malicious,
but maybe like dishonest. Dishonest. Yeah, disingenuous, I would
say, for sure. Okay. Is this Hold on. 10:15 p.m. That would be
What time was the content nuke coming out at? So, it's 10:15
p.m. Is this This would be what? UTC
almost certainly right 10:15 p.m. I'm trying to think of when
that is UTC how I transformed that into my time. Somebody who's
got the time stamps or who can do this just to go figure. I believe
this is when it would have started. Like there was a countdown.
I don't believe there's any reason to believe that before that
countdown was getting close to being done that that she wouldn't
have had that she would have had like a ton of viewers. Two two
or three. Somebody somebody just take I'll put this link in chat.
Somebody just go figure out if this is exactly when it dropped
because I I can't. Okay, I'm not going to do the the time zone
math on stream. It would be very boring. I don't think I like
summarizing Ethan as a dishonest person. I just think that sometimes
uh controversy and like I don't know topics like Israel Palestine.
It brings like the most sensitive parts of us out. And so this
just seems really personal, which means the nastier sides of
us can come out. And based on like how he's behaving throughout
this, but I've seen like him be a a kind person numerous times,
though. That's what's uh that's what's really annoying about
all of this. Is that just me? I feel like this wasn't who he
was. Oh, sorry. You're asking me. I sounded like you were reading
a chat. No, it wasn't just you. I don't think that's who he was.
I think it's mostly coming from like a place of hurt slash like
over time, right? Over time, you like lose track of how how different
you're acting. I think is very different than than who he was.
You don't even realize when you've become the Karen. You don't
realize you're the crazy woman calling the police on a guy just
like walking his dog. Yeah. Shut it down says it's the Dan Saltman
influence. He argued with FCC about this. It was pretty personal.
I maybe maybe I that might be something again I have to watch
cuz I my remembrance of it is very different that he had a whole
bunch of moral arguments that were very consistent like lefty
moral arguments about how it was taking money from smaller people
and and collecting it all hoarding it for rich people. I remember
the entire discourse around that. Remember when we got the video
from Meat Canyon on XQC?
Like this was this was such a big part of this discussion for
everybody,
right? Then you see is this dragon who's hoarding all of these
things, all of these all of the dollars from streaming from other